pouce bienvenu sur public sénat premier
numéro d' allons plus loin je suis ravi
de vous retrouver nous sommes ensemble
pendant deux heures deux heures en
direct avec vous on va prendre le temps
d'analyser de questionner toute
l'actualité politique parlementaire mais
aussi international vous allez le voir
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro
de votre émission les matins du sénat
vous allez être plongés au coeur des
travaux de la haute assemblée
[Musique]
le président de talissieu lui simplement
déjà ça
et naturellement de vendredi devant le
grand lyon 6ème un problème numéro un à
la fois de ne pas avoir pu mettre en
bouche plutôt dans le granit ou marbre
sur le verbe moins envie que ce tournoi
il est ainsi nourrir vos réflexions sur
la composition danse avait déposé la
semaine dernière nous était notamment en
banque
on a ça prendre fonction de management
investit la commission d'ouvrir mon
activité est donc la raison pour
laquelle le collègue clément et olivier
roux les présenter tu les remarques
liminaires simplement parce que quelques
éléments questions abordent le sentiment
par exemple puissamment à al-anbar en
france à l'aller nous sommes un acteur
majeur
l'investissement en matière de e en
prendre la mesure
kébé aussi peu d'intérêt y est simple
nouvellement en matière dire également
que la parade sentiment que certains
voudraient opposer aux musulmans nous
gagnons moins cher n'est pas la bonne
solution parce qu'on est parce qu il y
aurait été donné après les faits ce
niveau en 20 tirs d'ozel dans le monde
le plus mauvais chiffre
confesse j'ai vu notre rapport que le
patron de la même quantité que lentement
c'est exactement le moment il faut quand
même de nos valeurs la production design
et énergie brute du pouce des
déblaiements vous en doutez par rapport
à ben sur le verdissement et nous aurons
un niveau bas le gouvernement nous a
même investi pour le volet écoeurement
et donc à ce titre nous avons des choses
à dire échappée d'une zone habitée à
resserrer les liens
nous devons matière venger
neymar a non seulement à profit ce
sentiment le grand acteur je sois dans
l'administration vers le monde mais pas
encore suffisamment qui ont été
réprimées
nous ne devrons de chez les profits et
j'aimerais visible dans les chambres le
temps d'essuyer une devanture et les
documents longs courriers c'est
d'ailleurs elle va finir sur deux
éléments ont globalement une paix devant
en ainsi nous devrions comme un
partenaire légitime et des systèmes pour
accorder quelques le nom de l'amour sans
que l'industrie numérique et mon garage
les experts aient omis de leur milieu
quelle est la différence roman est bien
mort bien que l'ensemble de ces sujets
ims
ils ont reconnu jusqu'à l'échelon local
je pense et il souvent
il est en langue avec l'invention du
jour avant de voir the team d'insistance
urbaniste et mével puisse y avoir accès
à l'événement a besoin profond dit je
suis là pour déguster ont certainement
dix ans - numérique en fin d'année mot
fusion devant une crise et la semaine
dernière sur artdco forme ou en réunion
en présence de bambou physiquement et en
france et n'a pas porté un ingénieur et
du foie
merci pour votre attention démarche de
santé et en chine nous avons à dire sur
les estivants du jeu dans la veine on
était en jeu merci ça donne mais ne
dément le nom je suis en charge et cette
image
cette équipe elle trouve la zone europe
moyen-orient et l'afrique
il m'avait donné l'expérience sur le
site en 2010 j'ai danse culièrement de
l'église qui est vraiment leur rôle à
mon temps pour décrire notre vision à
d'échanger l'enfant talent et peut
expliquer qu'on fait pour résoudre
elle est également la première autorité
la deuxième concerne l'innovation qui tu
as khroub chine ils ont déjà produit il
a trois priorités
il s'élève la fédération de nos bleus le
charmant on rend l'utilisation
d'énergies renouvelables
la pension de l'énergétique dans le
produit aussi dans nos astuces
l'indispensable dans les projets et le
carreau et on est depuis peu et on l'a
fait pour l'heure six tickets restants
moustiques et cet engagement il vise à
nous revenir un peu neutre en carbone
d'ici 2030 pour tout le cycle de vie du
roi des limbes en damant sur ce qui est
évidemment mais le choix est un genre
débit son élection au togo si lui aussi
sur la capture et sa stratégie est libre
de s'habiller
le premier billet en scène en section
verbale de la bande de gaza
oui mais aussi d'améliorer ge réglant le
deuxième pilier concerne l'efficacité
n'en est pas bon il s'agit d'intégrer
d'efficacité énergétique dans les
jardins casse et composants qui sont
plus efficaces même si le logiciel dans
les concerts de parler mais aussi de
deux ans regardent également la
réduction les émissions directes versées
aux parents réunionnais énormité wazi en
passant de l'année et joue en rouge
enfin le cinquième et dernier billet de
2e rima tic ont ce qui reste y compris
des solutions qui sont nés sur la nature
alors pour passer notre il commence une
mesures détaillées de notre essai tendre
progressiste de l'été nos opérations qui
seront gérés en gros toutes ces
opérations elles font déjà alimenté en
tunisie et dans les garderies
il est lié qu'à toi
ensemble articulations et 100 %
seulement à l'adulte et leurs objectifs
ils étaient utilisés dans les gènes
rayonnement et la à la une en ce moment
100 renouvelable et il nous semble
indispensable et l'exemple pour le moins
possible car ils ont peur de nous on a
partagé nourrissante
vous avez notre expérience les posteurs
payer il propose des formations et des
outils et le monster munch tenait
ils ont fait pour elle on n'avait que 8
gigawatts l'engagement non bien sûr
et les défis et les instruments à
utiliser et ce nombre
quand il faut pas aussi les carences de
la demande en électricité qui attend nos
efforts d'élimination du carbone ont un
autre domaine clé et lui 2015 mais aussi
des congés de nuit et en chine mais
aussi aux clients
c'est vraiment pas qu'ils vont vouloir
oublier constation de tennis qu il est
l'ensemble du cycle de vie grande pompe
à fric
il a déjà conduit à une réduction de 35%
si on a réussi
et forcément ça ne la supporte
il ouvre en jeu produit on arrive qu'on
est régulière depuis 2007 sur des gens
et je vais le garder a les ressources
terrestres et il faut bien sûr second
silence et xt multi
il est fabriqué à vos nombreux de lier
en dix ans et de nombreuses couronnes là
et ça nous a narré de vivre en fonction
nous avons également en réduisant
longueurs devant deux extrêmes quelle
était la caricature
alors faut y aller il faut transformer
le noyau avec les chiens n'ont pas
répondu hier de nouvelles manières son
extrême continuellement et les
terrifiants et lonza va venir ou non à
ma réponse massive modèle circulait en
utilisant uniquement et renouvelables
étant d'éliminer non
présence à l'exportation des engrais
safran en visionnement on n'a pas vu un
aspect là aussi en utilisant un matériel
cars est aussi important en national
allemand munich et vient le temps du
loup géanges aussi en enrôlant
réputation ur et on adore effectué une
analyse solide et la gesture a donné les
impacts sociaux ça va être
officiellement plus chaque intelligence
et les pauvres et les petits nouveaux et
d identité hybride 4 ans et margot sa
présence et l'on se parle
toner je voudrais crier victoire
une graine pour imager le premier temps
le retour automatique
c'est à dire le moteur est bien statique
il est monté à l'horizon c'est le nom me
on tiendrait plus de 40 ans
l'instruction est devenue une cité alors
produit va arriver on a réduit de lanvin
à l'entraînement pour le maintien on a
commencé ses objectifs de nous
impressionner
ouais j'ai et on y fait des gens
loin et demandent le paiement en bois
issus de on a cherché des responsables
syndicaux on se soutient
thd
quand j'ai réussi et en chine
on est là pour avec insistance ic2 on
avait une chaîne d'approvisionnement au
motif que la fibre dover de quoi nous
risquons star dont la chaîne audio on
regarde les normes c'est aussi il
m'assure novembre laisse ouverte la
panoplie des armes et non pour sa part
également ensemble et on a un produit
très bon acheter un couple de matériaux
offerts ont montré de nouveaux marchés
comment changer à cette ville et à la
communauté rom aux principes et on l'a
fait partie importante de pollen cession
et la durabilité les interactifs vers
man et iron man est identique au team
décision est longue
on vise à créer des agrafes support de
mac os et qu'il néglige venant
l'entretien mots qui devrait contenter
les objectifs de plus rempli les
conditions non apurées chaleur extrême
et les versions anglaise et l'on soit en
dur et durable ou si des mises à jour
logicielles durable antiquités des
plafonds et l'objectif étant de
maintenir lyon tenir cet objectif de 6
ans sans avoir à faire pratiquer les
tarifs de la ration survie fia 2010
parce qu'on pense tu l'as fait part à
munich et paris et non stratégiques une
réparation et les espaces prévus sur
mais celle utilisée pièces dont une en
tant qu'événement conçu et deuxièmement
les réparations de pognon pour fournir
aux clients une tension de rio a bola
annonce en 6 à un programme iron t il à
le speedo et accéder aux mêmes outils
formation manuel de maurer l'année libre
et gratuite par nouveau remaniement m
garantit que nos appareils ils ont
transité besoin d'en acheter un
mais l'enseignement gratuit on a
développé des solutions
les matériaux ont disparu le 10 avril
et si long du concert les principes et
et on a créé par pays
mais lady demander de mieux
10 euros
le démontrer sur 200 m avec un modèle on
a deux des digues
d'ailleurs nous obéir à des règles de ce
sport permet à renault de revoir les
marchés ont pris le nom d'un objectif de
google cars vie heureusement les
augustins est en cours on utilise des
matériaux de dollars et l'espagne en pro
b messieurs les légistes fissures
internes issement de sa part insisté
et cette année on allait gérer les gangs
en images des gouvernants nous rhdp dit
qu'il rédige
et démontre le moteur de le femme compte
récupérer un élément merci à lui et à
ses avoirs
forcément reprendre 600 voix riche n'ose
y voit la manière et consisteront
comment êtes-vous
on utilise de nombreuses en
désapprouvant le motif
au passage il est fils de joindre aucune
on peut citer qu un exemple de
partenariat public privé j'y suis né là
on a envie de casser le stockage et de
récupération de l'eau de l'iss temps me
manque et qui retient dès lors vous
donner une meilleure vie de star j'en ai
même inclinés 6 tient en tournée vers
oran où les monétaristes 1 et 2
milliards $ obligation de rester à quai
sur la grille est totalement engagée
même si j'avais les moyens je vous
remercie d'avoir qu'il eu le temps avec
des voix
mais je me dis rien je devins d'une
question et et la voix et la madame x et
qu'elle vaut mais si vous envisagez de
vêtements grâce aux arrêts libéré que
nous apprendra à parce que ya une
politique est forte demande se situant
les mauvaises idées aux parents de bande
a vendu à nouveau citoyen et elles 120
ont dit que quand te dire dans mingora
nous est récupéré ou s'est elle aussi
créé leur parler et on sait l'effet de
caumont ainsi comment lundi de nouveaux
citoyens par fono vie des citoyens quand
il est peu liquide et matinée je pense
que les gens seront prêts en devises
on espère enfin décidé à enlever les
pistes pour m'entraîner c'est non holler
si le construire
on a rénové
parra manque la cité de belgique il
assurer la pérennité et le monde
musulman après le million de personnes
c'est normal
en fait le premier actionnaire de notre
vie touchait ce design au musical
durable nous retrouver il est hyper
longueur on y voit une deux et même à
paris il vouloir voir une convenance
devant une belle et si nous prenons la
phénoménale ne finissent pas dans les
[Musique]
six ans est aussi nombreux films en
augmenter tout à fait d'avoir des leurs
il ya aussi un phénomène mondial
question le consommateur mot d'avoir
mission éducation sur l'environnemental
et géant vantant les mentions éducation
communication dimanche mais ici
pas nous mais nos ventes progressent de
nyon enfin il ya un dernier le dernier
devant il y aura utilisé dans le match
emotionnellement portes du rêves de te
pleurent et leur force et leur part nous
clients ne sont pas prêts les absents
une bon droit donc savourer pendant les
incidents de pouvoir déclencher le dance
floor et i'm your man et sa relation
avec les égorgeurs ans qui a revu le
bilan mais bonjour jeudi par peur car
j'ai dansé par un must à la présence
vraiment indispensable la chance
d'apprendre et pour être efficace le
premier objectif est d'être un jeu
j'utilisais et de répondre à toutes ses
questions ou problèmes en peu de temps
c'est nouveau meeting chômage
j'appelle un nouveau point de départ est
le sens de chaque discussion du service
charlot c'est pourquoi uniquement la
satisfaction clients de nos utilisateurs
en province de konya son parcours et la
modestie nous devons marcher le perdre
en france par exemple en ce 4
or comme on réfléchit satisfaction quant
à la finalisation par lots l'amour lui
et de l'attachement au pays et on peut
noter nous fortement sur deux séances où
les exigences sur l'apple store de vente
en ta mentalité et de vérité de réponse
et maintenant daniel c'est le coordonner
au mieux des deux piliers après vente
que ce soit au service et le support
pour vous faire l'amère expérience
j'ai commencé par tenir piliers qui le
service aujourd'hui nous nous amusions
je parle de tout
une centaine en proximité par contre si
mauvais dans le département avec vous ma
mère de l'artiste collaboration entre
partenaires locaux ces centres
accueillent tous les consommateurs quel
que soit le produit 36 46 mg avec ou
sans rendez vous notre élan et manque de
consentement bien musclé entre deux
moments ils ont avancé des solutions
additionnel pouvoir d aider le
hennissement devra s'appuyer sur leur
connexion compétences pour pouvoir
développer ses services avant ce sommet
celle de proximité des soutenu à une
petite et moyenne portée régionale
nous avons finalement environ ou
technicien aurait dit par exemple en
champagne ardennes ile société
vocalement cette année et qui
aujourd'hui à 10 ans on a lancé
trente ans par son activité du dépôt et
l'enfant sont ils juste à versailles
devant une france vraiment dépenses
exactement la même aune là même de
l'histoire allemande presse on a des
partenaires de vos deux ans de service
des bouquets manche où tout le monde un
bleu sur la partie réparations sont ces
montures et loire le centre de proximité
on obtienne un réseau d'une trentaine de
sites sur lesquels ils sont chez les
opérateurs et revendeurs pouvoir les
aider la personne ainsi que des
mouvements spécifiques
alors où se vendront d'un pas tranquille
évidemment en selle renconter d'un
moment pas de calais ou en bretagne par
exemple je fais de leur expertise et de
l'oraison clément notez tout à l'heure
c'était un plaisir des larmes au prince
elle veut nous voir comme un tracteur à
dépendre il souhaitait accéder à
l'information
ainsi petits et une pièces détachées
d'origine pour la réparation en garde
alors c'est important contingent de la
sécurité des techniciens et que je suis
utilisateur
le rapport a nettement bénéficié
également de faire face à elles de créer
ensemble que disent pas forcément des
pièces aux gens nous restons à 2d sont
heureux d'avoir d'une centaine
d'entreprises françaises postuler à la
morue en antennes sont en déjà en action
de 8 voix de conversion d'un nouveau
crédit
évidemment en plus de ses solutions de
proximité je ne peux oublier mes
collègues un magasin rappeur connaissez
parès un sur paris et en province hasard
ou non mais j'ai pas les moyens puissent
conserver sa sociologie avec voeckler en
matière de ça concernant la partie
support aux lois françaises
on sait en scène posez vous une qui tue
deux centres d'appels pour deux sites
sont en france elle ce support est
important et nous allons les demandes
des consommateurs
cet article et si le client à 12 ans
justement réparti de façon à pouvoir
londres services de simplement pouvoir
répondre à la pression
héritage et ce site aride ou sans
rendez-vous leur niveau de recyclage aux
savoirs de toutes les pièces détachées
pour échanger et parler ou collectées
par apple vient de 1700 de services en
regard aux images ont parlé des machines
on désire et c'est un élément de concret
sur les paiements par voir et on va
pouvoir citer les clients et pouvant
dans les batteries pour nous pas mal il
faut m'expliquer donc ça c'est pour la
partie services mairie qui le crime
horrible et juste à vernoux sur la
qualité la durabilité de nos centres de
services et nos partenaires on à
disposition pendant ce temps des pistes
déjà chez lui à bâle pour tous les
partenaires à quoi celui-ci donné un
bisou du rallye et je pense qu'on est
des ménages même si donc le jouer merci
pour vos intérêts
transmission heureusement d'écouté
orange paris on me le prendrais les
innovations opérette du numérique
tellement de chansons a développé dans
ce rapport exposées elles il ya les
gouvernants sur l'information le sang et
les gouttes par essence un été tout en
prenant 0,82 le remplacement du parc du
mans rennes et driss différemment sinon
le bras mort on a prôné la limitation
également en bouclier millions de
munitions pu quitter le sol essence des
cars au salon devront nature et depuis
les terminaux installés en une seule
essence désire prendre entreprises des
landes a marre d'être cité dans mean ans
nous lie les mains en ce moment t on ce
batteur du dernier lien ci dessous les
sens matériel et les drones ou merde à
la principale les variances dans un camp
ou dans tendance des granites arinso
l'essence programmée il est créé en 2000
quand une puni de 9 ans en règlement
nous à son niveau d'avant leur encours à
l'éthique reluisant
à strictement aucune condamnation les
[Musique]
entendre l'avis de plusieurs
associations
la pratique de même que lentement
diffusée en raison de l'article comme la
niche fuite est venue notamment dans la
nécessité pour les associations pour
l'explorateur douroux et
l'intentionnalité par élection d'année
nous confirmons le conseil national nous
précisément de la guerre des munitions
et une lutte renforcée contre logeuse
dans des doigts de nature à ramener à
l'avantagé comparatif environnement les
mules arrière maintenant à une
connaissance initiale ont visiblement
accéléré les initiales du commencement
des graves événements nous constituons
slughorn soliste ans aura mais sont les
consommateurs à renouveler en smartphone
ou d'un délit d'ailleurs plusieurs
articles chambre lui la multi concept le
sommet sans ce logiciel notamment la
colonisation
ce tassement des mises à jour de
sécurité
on lui met inutilement également
brévinois enfin nous permettre un
ordinateur installé deux joueurs étaient
bien des versions de l'intérieur des
miliciens dont ni le renard et la gloire
en libéral ainsi qu'elle revient dans
des sociétés elle m'en donne pour
mission lensoise mais ils s'aiment et
arnaud merci mon dieu merci à mes yeux
l'une des meilleures conditions jours
en tient ici d'un revenu notre objectif
n'est pas de courber numérique tout à
fait conscient telle externalités
positives au nouveau règlement des voies
biliaires et le syrien d'evry n'a pas
venu vers et non la pauvreté
considérablement
elle va augmenter que faiblement parce
que les autres secteurs des corps et
biens sans à sa parole a dit moment et
donc pas parce que les données sont
multipliés par deux ou trois ans et
parce que nous avons aussi une
démultiplication des capitaux les
identités des peuples est souvent les
moins connectés en pré cités ce qui va
et les objets de l'été et peut-être les
mines scott mckay l'explosion entre les
mais c'est harry qu'aucun haut
rang sans avoir une vie n'est que de
faire fuiter décarbonée c'est madame qui
est et osant ordinaire il est important
même s'il faut évidemment être fiers les
sous-titrés en faire évidemment le cycle
denis des terminaux et organiser ma
vision pour tourcoing hurle c'est la
durée de vie chez eux et demain on ira
changer le modèle économique à ce bon
roi de même bien que le champion le
délai qu'il fixe avec la suite à
fonctionnalité dans la propriété à des
gosses on n'est pas propriétaire
une question peut être est ce que c'est
quelque chose d'immense temps la chaux
d'achat de changer le modèle économique
pour les derbys volant rien n'est
cependant pas oublier des chemins de
l'avenir les églises ouvert le sauver ce
n'est plus avec vos nombreux pays où les
données comparables alors ensuite
réduction de 2,2 d'alluré îles à sion au
le délai de conformité de 2010 notamment
pour les versions 2 abandon à l'appel et
des autres compétitions parallèles il
loupe et le royaume uni l'allemagne a
remporté toutes les dispositions le
dollar par action il ya un an vient vous
avez parlé de son appel le cas ni est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
ensuite simplement encore droguerie et
gérer la base du titre elisa dollar or
il en consomme d'ajuster ben ali est un
commercial et buzz où on est le mans
ainsi d enlever les mancelles
utilisateurs à me dire et puis et puis
donc beaucoup d'eau justement ce recours
et emploi et puis d'être stimulé le soin
délégation de porte et les roumains si
mu une usine en sicile est l'inventeur
pour ces questions les danses poésies de
coller encore en appoint et mise en
commun des dons destinés
l'élément tu peux commencer joyeusement
sur les questions de licences
logicielles les provinces et l'empreinte
carbone
chacun s'est produit en novembre
précisément et quelques jours cette
position de m
[Musique]
là il a le dessus
une analyse très détaillée produits et
les données vu une idée et là on
retrouve celle h 30 sur la chaîne de
fabrication
on était là et les ados dit il
c'est une coupe elise est jamais aussi
mythique de quelques heures une durée ni
le monial à la première ni la jeune
fille a déjà pris les 2e et italie
au regard des neuf en apprenant pirates
lancent en lice n'ont hélas kerry est
garanti chiffres comme je lé relais de
lassouts ses 20e c'est que je sais
y aurait il un troisième élément qu'elle
inaugure manqué un contrôle en totalité
d'alluré la garantie alors pour
plusieurs vies
iron conditionné dans glengarry table et
l'a42 passant de barbara cette question
j'ai choisi ce sujet restait leur guise
de présent je les aide humanitaire en
anglais de garantie qui ses parents
je le sais les beaux jours des documents
par l'assuré copé devant la presse en
référence à les conditions sur
lesquelles effectivement ça nous fera le
tri qui à partir de là c'est le
contraire modifiable au coeur du sujet
de reconditionner les annexes puis à
luzenac ce matin pensez à prendre
marie justine éléments le bim asie il va
le vivre et mourir
on va essayer de maximiser électivement
au centre à leurs utilisateurs l'accès à
ces moments il soit environ sept vertus
guerrières
je viens là mais c'est quelque chose
soit on est très attaché on va essayer
d'amener les consommateurs et leur goût
alors je sais pas sur lesquels
effectivement on voit que des comités
sur le marché en 2015 mordu merabet les
flocons deschamps logiciel mais le
logiciel
[Musique]
vraiment permis à relancer nouvelle là
on a simplement vous justement mis sur
l'implication et l'investissement sont
ses cheveux à l'eau sans rien par
ailleurs je voulais m'en tire également
sur deux des corps plats originaux non
denses par et les propositions d'une
route auront exactement les mêmes
extraits proposés par les rapporteurs
gdt notamment l'égalité en ce moment
même langage et google les mots qui
donnent de vrais bons puisque je suis
non je suis extrêmement content est
évidemment plus pour être localisé
comme nous sommes éligibles à perdre et
la question c'est qu'est la commission
de la jud ciel de cet engagement à
d'élus largement d'ailleurs sur les
sujets ligne en environnement numérique
on va résister et éviter de prêter comme
les favoris sont stagnants ch
l'ensemble de la chaîne et il est
notamment le cas sur le logiciel on va
la question de l'autre liste
cochrane et le site un délit devait de
le mentionner à la connaissance aucun
industriel
la commission pour le casque est
absolument actuellement et l'objectif
donc le bon sens étranger
la france a beau vous sur les bourses
asiatiques au rendement sur leur
légitimité dans le rôle de l'entourage
mouz et au mais ils nous avaient pas sur
des vérités un mystique elle est pour
moi peuvent donc saisir et les choses
maintenant nous confions existe
le legend pour amy ça n'existe pas chez
elle sur cette finale et c'est l'objet
des débats laissant ce logiciel donc
arrivé dans ce ciel même si là aussi une
étude quelque chose d'humour la réalité
de cette situation et de voir dans les
événements lui en suis venue des jeux
paris et le jour de leurs avoirs à un
organisme devra ce qu'on a des éléments
actuels et les eaux je n'avais vraiment
aller les filles on est preneur parce
que ça permet sont complexes sensibles
des idées pour lequel on avait très peu
d'électeurs de mauvaises pratiques
au fond nous nous logiciel intégré vous
avez un terminal de la marque apple
le logiciel est intégré et drogba
n'était du logiciel décorer l'intérieur
elie la limmat et du muy ciel ne va pas
c est donc l humanité vous venez de
matériel est conforme également une
liste il ya vous retrouver par exemple
il aurait pas vous terminerez le nom
final logiciel ou partie du système
parce que vous parle nous remet à la
question de savoir qui est responsable
entre le pavé lyonnais savoure en juger
voilà nous allons interrompre la
diffusion de ses auditions en condition
en raison des conditions techniques qui
ne sont pas assez satisfaisante avec
toutes nos excuses bien sûr à la place
nous
nous proposons de suivre maintenant
l'audition de bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie était auditionné hier au
sénat sur le plan de relance et sur le
projet de loi de finances pour 2021
on regarde et on se retrouve après à
tout à l'heure je voudrais d'abord avoir
évidemment un mot de soutien au corps
enseignant des yvelines qui a été
particulièrement touché par la tragédie
de conflans sainte honorine
c'est dire à quel point je suis
déterminé comme ministre des finances à
lutter contre les réseaux de financement
du terrorisme
nous préparons des propositions pour le
président de la république pour que pas
un euro depuis salée en france ni au
financement du terrorisme ni aux
associations qui peuvent avoir le
moindre lien avec le terrorisme ou avec
l'islam politique
nous travaillons dans trois directions
d'abord les circuits de financement des
associations dites cultuelle culturelles
ou sportives mais qui en fait cachent
des réseaux de l'islam politique qui
soutiennent l'islam politique et son
objectif de destruction de la nation
française de ses valeurs de son histoire
ou de sa culture
nous travaillons également à lutter
contre l'anonymat
décryptons monnaie qui permettent de
financer des activités liées au
terrorisme
nous travaillons enfin dans une
troisième direction qui est la
responsabilité des plateformes
numériques
c'est probablement l'enjeu le plus
important celui qui sera le plus
difficile mais vous connaissez ma
détermination à obtenir une juste
régulation des plateformes digitales
ça passe par leur taxation ça passe
aussi par la responsabilité qu'elles
doivent avoir dans les contenus qui
circulent sur les réseaux digitaux quand
des messages qui appellent à la haine
qu'ils appellent directement à la
vengeance contre un enseignant sont
diffusés sur un réseau social
ce réseau ne pas pas considérer qu'il ne
porte aucune responsabilité dans la
diffusion
de ces messages pas tout ce qu'on
demande à un éditeur quand on lui
demande de retirer un livre qui
comporterait des propos haineux lés
propos qui appellent à la violence
pourquoi cette obligation qui est fait à
un éditeur ne se ferait pas pour une
plateforme numérique
ma détermination à mettre les
plateformes numériques devant leurs
responsabilités par rapport à nos
sociétés et par rapport à nos valeurs
est totale au-delà de cela je voulais
profiter de cette audition pour dire à
quel point le défi qui est devant nous
un défi considérable
nous sommes je l' ai dit à plusieurs
reprises confronté à une crise qui n'a
pas d'équivalent en france depuis un
siècle
c'est à dire la grande récession de 1929
nous avons perdu à cause du virus
en l'espace d'un an 10% notre production
nationale notre richesse nationale
ça représente parfois certains ont
tendance à l'oublier et se disent dans
deux mois dans trois mois tout ça sera
derrière nous non évidemment que
lorsqu'il y à une chute aussi importante
du produit national brut notre richesse
nationale et c'est vrai dans tous les
autres pays européens et c'est vrai aux
états unis et c'est vrai dans beaucoup
d'autres pays à travers la planète
il faut du temps pour se redresser et
nous faudra au moins deux ans pour
retrouver notre niveau de développement
économique d'avant crise niveau de
développement économique ou l'avait
rappelé qu'ils étaient satisfaisants et
tout le défi pour nous tous pas
simplement pour le ministre de
l'économie et des finances mais pour les
entrepreneurs pour les parlementaires
que vous êtes pour la société française
tout entière va être de combiner
protection des salariés et des
entreprises face à la crise et relancer
l'activité économique
pour préparer la france à l'après crise
et je ne renoncerai ni à l'un ni à
l'autre
je compte au contraire continuer à
protéger des salariés les entreprises
qui en ont le plus besoin
qui
confronté aux obligations sanitaires
liées au couvre-feu et dans le même
temps investir dans l'avenir dans les
nouvelles technologies dans la 5g dans
l'hydrogène dans le calcul quantique
dans la formation des salariés parce que
nous vous faites aucune illusion
la crise fera des vainqueurs elle fera
des vaincus la chine sortira grand
vainqueur de cette crise du point de vue
économique et sans doute du point de vue
financier
je souhaite que la france et l'europe
sorte aussi grand vainqueur de cette
crise ce qui suppose que nous
expliquions avec le plus de
détermination possible à nos
compatriotes que protégé dans l'immédiat
n'exclut pas de préparer pour le futur
et c'est bien l'objectif qui est le mien
afficher un volontarisme économique de
tous les instants de tous les jours de
toutes les semaines pour que nous
puissions protéger notre économie et la
préparer en même temps aux défis futurs
sur la protection
je crois que vous connaissez l'ampleur
de ce qui a été mis en place
je rappelle juste rapidement les prêts
garantis par l'état 120 milliards
d'euros qui ont été décaissés 6
milliards d'euros d' aide aux
indépendants aux commerçants et aux
artisans aux très petites entreprises à
travers le fond de solidarité des
reports d'échéances fiscales et sociales
pour 42 milliards d'euros depuis le mois
de mars 22 milliards d'euros pour le
chômage partiel
tout cela pour éviter des centaines de
milliers de licenciements et des
dizaines de milliers de faillite
les chiffres sont clairs 38 me une
entreprise en fait faillite en août 2000
20 53 milles en août 2019 camp de regard
sur les douze derniers mois
il y a eu 30 % de faillite en moins en
france en 2020 par rapport à 2010 9 en
raison des mesures de soutien que nous
avons apportées
nous avons eu sept cent cinquante mille
destructions d'emplois environ
c'est un chiffre qui est considérable et
qui touche les plus précaires qui touche
les cdd qui touche les intérimaires et
touche les personnes les moins
qualifiées mais le chiffre aurait été
mille fois plus important si nous
n'avions pas mis en place les mesures de
chômage partiel que nous avons décidé
avec le président de la république et le
premier ministre
beaucoup de nos compatriotes souffrent
aujourd'hui de la situation
certains sont tombés dans la pauvreté et
nous voulons leur apporter des réponses
mais je rappelle quand même que le
pouvoir d'achat moyen des français n'a
été réduit que de 0 25%
quand l'activité chuté de 10 donc nous
avons fait le maximum pour protéger les
français et nous continuerons à faire le
maximum pour protéger les français
certains me disent mais est ce que tout
cela ne risque pas de coûter trop cher
est ce que cette politique n'est pas
aventureuse dans cette politique et les
responsables et je me félicite que la
présidence de la banque centrale
européenne christine lagarde et
rappelait encore aujourd'hui qu'il
fallait que les états continuent de
soutenir en 2020 et en 2021
les entreprises et des salariés je me
félicite que christine lagarde ait eu la
lucidité de rappeler que rien ne serait
plus irresponsable que de couper court à
ces mesures de soutien au moment où
elles produisent tous leurs effets donc
ça vous surprendra peut-être de la part
d'un ministre des finances mais je suis
bien déterminé à continuer à dépenser
l'argent nécessaire pour nos
compatriotes pour l'emploi et pour les
entreprises
parce qu'il est moins cher de financer
des projets de développement pour un
ingénieur aéronautique qui aujourd'hui
privés tout développement chez airbus et
thales et safran
où est chez dassault parce que le trafic
aérien s'est effondré je préfère que
l'état français financent les actions
des formations des projets pour cet
ingénieur plutôt que cet ingénieur
soient licenciés
et que les dix ou douze années d'études
qu'il a fallu et de formation qu'il a
fallu pour avoir un ingénieur de niveau
mondial soit perdue est gaspillée par
son licenciement
je préfère qu'on dépense beaucoup
d'argent dans les prêts garantis par
l'état pour sauver notre capital
industriel est notre capitale économique
plutôt que de le laisser s'effondrer et
ensuite ne plus avoir les moyens de le
redresser
les dépenses que nous faisons
actuellement sont un investissement
un investissement pour l'avenir des
français un investissement pour l'avenir
de notre économie
cette dette atteindra donc eu 117 g 2 5%
du pib en 2020 soit une augmentation
chère sophie primas d'environ 20 points
par rapport à l'année dernière
nous sommes dans le temps de la dépense
publique et nous continueront à l'être
tant que le virus circulera c'est la
position la banque centrale européenne
c'est la position du ministre de
l'économie et des finances telle qu'elle
a été proposée par le président de la
république est décidée par le président
de la république
mais le moment venu quand nous
commencerons à voir l'horizon
s'éclaircir c'est à dire je l'espère
d'ici la fin de l'année 2021 début 2022
avant de retrouver notre pleine
croissance et à dire je l'espère dans le
courant de l'année 2022
il faudra rembourser cette dette ce
n'est pas le moment
mais le moment viendra et je ne laissait
aucune ambiguïté devant les français sur
ce sujet comment est ce que nous les
rembourserons la rembourseront d'abord
pas la croissance que nous aurons
retrouvé rombourg jamais de dette sans
croissance
la dette publique a besoin de croissance
pour être remboursé
c'est l'instrument le plus efficace et
le plus durable de réduction de la dette
le deuxième moyen pour répondre à compte
la question de ce qui prime c'est la
maîtrise de nos finances publiques nous
devons continuer à faire preuve de
responsabilité sur les finances
publiques notamment sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement
c'est ce que
on fait en 2021 en refusant toute
augmentation du nombre de fonctionnaires
dans la fonction publique d'état
enfin je pense qu'il faut avoir le
courage de dire à nos compatriotes parce
qu'ils le savent que seules des réformes
structurelles permettront de garantir
des finances publiques saines sur le
long terme et le parmi ces réformes
structurelles la réforme la plus
importante celle qui permet de garantir
l'équilibré de nos comptes sociaux de
nos comptes publics en général c'est la
réforme des retraites tous les français
comprennent que si nous voulons
continuer à financer un système de
protection sociale qui est un des plus
généreux et des plus efficaces au monde
si nous voulons mieux nous occuper de
nos aînés notamment sur les questions de
dépendance
nous devons également augmenter le
volume global de travail dans notre pays
et comprenez moi bien c'est pas une
accusation contre qui que ce soit la
france est un peuple gens qui
travaillent de professionnels de gens
qui aiment leur travail qui sont
compétents qui sont efficaces qui sont
productifs chaque personne qui travaille
travaille beaucoup et travaille durement
en france mais il n'y a pas suffisamment
de personnes qui travaillent d'abord
parce que les jeunes entrent plus tard
sur le marché du travail ensuite parce
que nous avons un taux de chômage qui
reste encore trop élevé et enfin parce
que nous sommes résignés dans une
politique jugent socialement
irresponsable et économiquement
contestable à faire partir des plus de
50 ans le plus vite possible de
l'entreprise pendant des décennies on a
expliqué que les personnes de plus de 50
ans était trop coûteuse et et d'un poids
pour une entreprise alors que je
considère au contraire qu'elle
représente de l'expérience est qu'à des
grands défis culturels que nous avons
c'est précisément de redonner toute leur
place aux plus de 50 ans dans la vie
économique de notre pays je vous
surprendrai peut-être en dix ans à la
cgt en a fait un de ces grands combats
je partage pas beaucoup de combats de la
cgt mais celui là celui sur l'emploi de
plus 50 ans je le partage
je pense qu'il est vital pour notre
nation ne peut pas dire qu'on veut
inciter les français à travailler plus
longtemps et continuer dans le même
temps à dire aux plus de 50 ans qui sont
des poids dans une entreprise
donc je le redis la réforme des
retraites est pour moi un des enjeux
stratégiques des grands équilibres
financiers et des grands équilibres
sociaux de notre nation dans les années
à venir protéger continuer de protéger
c'est aussi renforcer les dispositifs
existants nous avons mis en place un
couvre-feu
il est indispensable du point de vue
sanitaire il est très pénalisant pour
beaucoup de professions et je salue la
manière dont l'hôtellerie la
restauration le monde du spectacle de la
culture se bat pour s'adapter à ces
règles sanitaires se bat pour s'ouvrir
plus tôt pour commencer plus tôt pour
finir aussi plus tôt et permettent
malgré tout à leur clientèle de
continuer à venir mais j'ai parfaitement
conscience aussi que pour beaucoup de
ces restaurateurs pour beaucoup de ces
gens du spectacle vivant ou de
l'événementiel les temps sont
terriblement dur terriblement dur et
nous ferons tout pour continuer à les
soutenir et adapter nos dispositifs le
fonds de solidarité gelé rétabli pour
toutes les entreprises tout qui sont
dans les géographies du couvre-feu
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés ont accès désormais à ce fonds
solidarité qui leur permet d'avoir
jusqu'à 1500 euros par mois pour les
secteurs les plus touchés l'hôtellerie
les cafés la restauration l'événementiel
les salles de sport les salles de cinéma
les salles de théâtre les salles de
concert nous avons porté le fonds
solidarité à 10000 euros par mois elles
peuvent bénéficier des 50 % de perte de
chiffre d'affaires au lieu de 70 et j'ai
supprimer le plafonnement à 60% du
chiffre d'affaires pour qu'elle puisse
aller le plus loin possible dans le
bénéfice de ce fonds j'ai également
proposé les exonérations de charges
sociales supplémentaires
aussi bien pour les cotisations
patronales
que pour les cotisations salariales sous
forme de crédits d'impôts l'ensemble de
ces mesures coûtent 1 milliard d'euros
elles ont été décidées la semaine
dernière donc vous le voyez à chaque
fois nous adaptons le dispositif pour
protéger mieux et davantage les
entreprises qui sont concernés nous
avons également traiter la question des
prêts garantis par l'état
ces prêts garantis par l'état je le
redis l'ont été un immense succès 120
milliards d'euros de décaisser dont 90%
pour des pme et des tpe
mais aujourd'hui vous en avez dans vos
territoires
beaucoup s'inquiètent en disant comment
est ce qu'on va faire pour rembourser
pour les plus fragiles
nous avons prévu en accord avec la
fédération bancaire française qu'elle
puisse reporter le début de leur
remboursement de mars 2021 à 2022 on va
leur donner un an supplémentaire pour
commencer le remboursement de leurs
prêts c'est un effort considérable il
sera fait au cas par cas je le précise
ce sera pas les 570 mille contrats à
terme être renégociés comme cela je
pense que ce serait bon pour personne
mais une entreprise qui est vraiment en
difficulté
elle pourra aller voir son banquier dire
écoutez je peux pas remboursés à partir
de mars
est-ce que je peux avoir six mois huit
mois 12 mois supplémentaires pour
commencer le remboursement
celles qui veulent est allé pour ont
étalé sur cinq années supplémentaires
soit six ans au total
elles pourront le faire avec des taux
particulièrement attractives
je les ai négocié avec la fédération
bancaire française ils seront compris
entre 1 et 2 5 % garantie de l'état
comprise qui représente 100 points de
base sur ses taux donc ce sont des taux
extraordinairement attractif et je tiens
à saluer l'esprit de responsabilité de
la fédération bancaire française qui
depuis le début de cette crise à
accompagner les entreprises et l'état
dans la politique de soutien à
l'économie pour les entreprises qui
souhaiteraient disposer de fonds propres
et qui se disent on est très endettée
mais nous maintenant veut investir on
veut sortir de la crise nous avons mis
en place des prêts participatifs dont je
préciserai le taux d'ici quelques
semaines
qui sont des prêts de long terme au delà
de sept ans des prêts qui sont des quasi
fonds propres
donc il ne pèse pas sur l'endettement
des entreprises et des prêts qui ne
donne pas droit à la modification du
capital de l'entreprise qui est une
vraie inquiétude des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire auquel nous avons
fait droit
j'avais indiquer au départ que nous
mettrions de milliards d'euros de
garantie de l'état sur ces prêts
participatifs pour lever de 10 à 15
milliards d'euros de prêts participatifs
nous avons vu que c'était insuffisant
pour beaucoup d'entreprises nous avons
donc changé la donne en disant que nous
fixions 20 milliards d'euros de prêts
participatifs comme objectif est que la
garantie de l'état s'adapterait à ce
volume global de prêts participatifs
si c'est plus de 2 milliards nous avons
prévu dans le projet de loi de finances
que ça peut être plus de 2 milliards
l'important c'est pas la garantie de
l'état
l'important c'est les prêts
participatifs pour les entreprises c'est
les fonds propres des entreprises
voilà pour les mesures de protection qui
sont donc le premier volet de mon action
protège et continuer à protéger aussi
longtemps que le virus sera là adapter
les dispositifs sans cesse faire preuve
de toute la souplesse nécessaire pour
que personne ne soit laissé au bord du
chemin
mais dans le même temps je le redis il
faut que la relance commençaient
commence maintenant
les mêmes qui me disait en juin pourquoi
est-ce que vous engagez pas la relance
tout de suite sont ceux qui me disent
maintenant pourquoi vouloir lancer pas
plus tard nous nous avons tenu je ne le
dis pas pour les sénateurs mais je l' ai
beaucoup entendu en dehors de cet
hémicycle les mêmes fois encore qu'ils
me disais qu'en juin il n'y avait pas
une semaine à perdre pour engager la
relance me disent maintenant c'est trop
tôt faut attendre la fin de la
circulation du virus non je n'attendrai
pas la fin de la circulation du virus
ronaldo qu'elle simple c'est je n'en
sais rien et qu'elle seule chose que je
sais c'est que c'est maintenant qu'il
faut investir maintenant qu'il faut
relancer
maintenant que notre économie doit
redémarrer la seule chose que je sais
c'est que nous devons concilier la lutte
contre le virus et le redémarrage de
l'économie la sécurité sanitaire et la
sécurité économique car cette sécurité
économique
elle est vitale pour des millions de
français c'est leur emploi c'est leur
rémunération
c'est leur fin de mois c'est leur
activité qui est en jeu c'est leur
psychologie sa sécurité personnelle
c'est la vie de leur famille qui est en
jeu et je me bats pour tout ça pour que
chaque français se disent l'économie
continue à tourner et c'est pas qu'un
slogan c'est une réalité quotidienne de
gens que vous avez sur vos territoires
qui ont envie d'aller travailler
quand je vois un restaurateur qui
bénéficient du fonds de solidarité la
première chose qui me dit on n'a pas
envie des donne envie de travail pour
eux c'est pas possible pour des raisons
sanitaires
mais je souhaite que pour le plus grand
nombre de français il soit possible de
continuer à travailler malgré la
circulation du virus
je constate d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui
toutes les mesures que nous avons
commencé à mettre en place fonctionne
remarquablement bien je dirais même trop
bien je donne l'exemple des fonds pour
la relocalisation industrielle
nous avons mis un milliard d'euros sur
ses fonds de relocalisations
industrielles dont 500 devaient être
dépensés en 2020 nous avions mille
projets environ il y a quelques semaines
on nous a dit les appels à projets sont
trop compliqué c'était une critique du
medef et de la ceppm la critique était
justifiée nous avons simplifié les
dispositifs nous avons désormais 3600
projets qui sont sur la table
d'entreprise de pme dans vos territoires
qui demandent 500 mille euros 1 millions
pour financer une ligne de production en
france plutôt qu'à l'étranger
nous avons 100 millions d'euros qui sont
déjà décaissé et nous aurons décaisser
les 500 millions d'euros avant la fin de
l'année il sera probablement nécessaire
de rapatrier le patri des crédits de
2021 sur 2020 tellement la demande de
fonds pour la relocalisation
industrielle est forte depuis que nous
avons lancé avec agnès pannier-runacher
ses projets deuxième exemple sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics
nous avions prévu de 2,7 milliards
d'euros nous avons aujourd'hui pour huit
milliards d'euros de demandes de
rénovation énergétique de bâtiments
publics universités caserne brigades de
gendarmeries commissariats
8 milliards d'euros de demandes pour
financer la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics
je souhaite vous indiquez puisque vous
représenter les territoires que notre
volonté avec le premier ministre est de
placer ces fonds au plus près possible
les territoires pour toutes les
rénovations énergétiques de moins de 5
millions d'euros
elles seront décidées au niveau local
par les préfets rien ne remontera
jusqu'à paris
seuls les rénovations énergétiques de
plus de 5 millions d'euros pour les
territoires 8 millions d'euros pour
l'ile-de-france remonteront à mon niveau
et je rendrai arbitrage le 20 novembre
prochain
je rappelle juste le 92 % des projets de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics sont à moins de 5 millions
d'euros
ça veut dire que l'immense majorité de
ces décisions seront traités au niveau
local s'agissant de toutes ces mesures
je rappelle que vous pouvez consulter le
site internet unique que nous avons
ouvert plan de relance point vert.fr qui
permettent à chacun de s'informer sur
les différentes mesures qui sont
disponibles et qui ont été mis en place
par le plan de relance
voilà les quelques éléments que je
voulais vous présenter je pète plus long
dans ma présentation sachant que j'ai
une contrainte horaire avec une réunion
chez le premier ministre à 19 heures
mais je voulais vous redire à quel point
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour moi est de
concilier cette protection de notre
économie et la relance qui doit nous
permettre d'ici deux ans de sortir plus
fort de cette crise
merci monsieur le ministre votre
intervention va appeler beaucoup de
questions je vais donner tout de suite
la parole je rappelle pour mes nouveaux
collègues en particulier qu'il faut se
signaler pour prendre la parole et je
vais vraiment être très strict sur les
deux minutes car vous êtes extrêmement
nombreux à poser des questions et le
ministre à une contrainte horaire
on commence par une chaleur chez merci
beaucoup respectez les deux minutes
monsieur le ministre la cause principale
du budget que vous nous présentez
aujourd'hui est bien évidemment la
relance de notre économie terminologie
qui a depuis l'été remplacer les mesures
d'urgence et les plans de soutien
ce nouvel objectif de relance que nous
nous fixions collectivement ne doit pas
faire oublier
que beaucoup de nos entreprises se
trouve aujourd'hui encore dans un urgent
état d'urgence économique
on anticipe une hausse de 80% des
faillites en france dans les prochains
mois des suppressions d'emplois
industriels sont déjà annoncés en dépit
des aides publiques
le quasi confinement imposé depuis ce
week-end va sans nul doute replonger les
restaurateurs et les débits de boissons
dans le rouge écarlate
ma question est donc la suivante comment
votre plan de relance répond-t-il à
cette urgence économique non pas dans
six mois dans un an dans cinq ans mais
dès qu'il sera voté
les nombreux dispositifs
d'accompagnement non financiers vers la
numérisation la décarbonation les appels
à manifestation d'intérêt se
transformeront il en énième guichet
méconnu des chefs d'entreprise la
superposition des dispositifs est source
de complexité ne retardera pelepas le
déploiement je m'interroge non seulement
sur les outils mais aussi les moyens que
se donne l'état pour les mettre en avant
les services régionaux de bercy par
exemple voient leurs effectifs se
réduire dans la mission économie nous
sommes tous conscients du rôle essentiel
qu'on jouait les cci ces derniers mois
vous avez renoncé de justesse à la
baisse de leurs financements à
l'assemblée le haut conseil des finances
publiques estimé il y a quelques jours
de cela au sénat que vos hypothèses de
décaissement c'est à dire la moitié des
100 milliards d'euros en 2021 se fonde
sur une vision je cite volontarisme de
l'effet des mesures du plan de relance
sur la croissance alors monsieur le
ministre
êtes vous trop optimiste montaugé
merci présidente ont ce ministre mes
questions concernant plus
particulièrement la mission économie et
les crédits dédiés au commerce à
l'artisanat de façon un peu provocatrice
je souhaiterais vous demander où sont
ils
progressivement les crédits soutient ce
secteur disparaissent de la mission
pense au fisac
mais pas uniquement et sont saupoudrés
dans d'autres missions et programmes
depuis l'an dernier en effet il n'ya
plus d'actions spécifiques dédiés au
commerce à l'artisanat
depuis cette année le fisac a disparu
depuis cette année également l'epareca
ou l' agence de numérique ont rejoint l'
agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires et ne relèvent donc plus de
cette mission
envisagez-vous d'améliorer l'information
du parlement regroupant les crédits
dédiés au commerce et à l'artisanat au
sein d'un même document
deuxième question porte sur la
numérisation des pme un besoin essentiel
la mission économie prévoit 2 millions
d'euros à destination de l'initiative
france nîmes dont beaucoup d'acteurs
déplore le manque de notoriété donc
l'inefficacité qu'envisagez vous le
faire pour rapprocher cette initiative
des entrepreneurs qui en ont réellement
besoin par ailleurs envisagez-vous de
simplifier et d'unifier les divers
dispositifs d aide à la numérisation qui
existent et qui s'il part d'une bonne
intention perdent les commerçants plus
qu'il ne les aide
enfin troisième dernière question
concerne le réseau des cci
le gouvernement a finalement annulé la
baisse de financement qu'il envisageait
pour 2021 c'est bien cependant au regard
des moyens l'énergie déployée par les
cci depuis le début de la crise
envisagez vous de les soutenir davantage
et non pas uniquement de retarder la
bâche de leur financement je remercie
merci serge franck montaugé ensuite anne
catherine loisier merci à la présidente
monsieur le ministre la crise actuelle
nous rappelle l'importance de
l'industrie dans l'économie nationale en
termes d'emplois et de fourniture de
biens stratégiques pharmaceutique par
exemple l'agroalimentaire ou
manufacturier la relocalisation doit
faire l'objet d'un plan structuré
discuter avec le parlement est ce que
vous le prévoyez m'échapper crise fait
aussi revenir la tentation de la
délocalisation pour nombre d'entreprises
qui ont déjà annoncé des plans sociaux
on constate que ces plans découle d'un
transfert d'activité
à l'étranger bridgestone a investi en
pologne thales en de renault en turquie
etc
dans ce contexte difficile nous devons
trouver un équilibre socialement
protecteur est économiquement efficace
entre d'une part les aides publiques à
nos industries et de l'autre les
contreparties à ces aides sur les
contreparties dans le cadre du contrôle
budgétaire exercée par le sénat
j'ai demandé à vos services de nous
donner la liste des engagements pris par
les entreprises du secteur aéronautique
et automobile dans le cadre des plans de
soutien votée en loi de finances
rectificative vos services ne m'ont pas
répondu
le délai fixé par la lolf et pourtant
dépassé pouvez-vous me répond
aujourd'hui sur ce point sur le premier
volet c'est à dire les aides c'est à
dire la réponse à l'urgence économique
il faut aller plus loin dans le soutien
aux pme et aux pays en matière de fonds
propres
vous avez annoncé que vous l'avez
rappelé la mobilisation de 20 milliards
d'euros de financement participatif
pouvez vous nous indiquer qu'elle selon
quels critères ceux ci seront attribués
aux entreprises car vous visez celle
avec je vous cite un vrai potentiel de
rebond
je crains que ne soit exclu tout un plan
de 1 panne de pme industrielles déjà
endetté avait la crise mais qui pourrait
se développer en investissant
accompagnons l'ensemble de notre tissu
productif local tout particulièrement
je vous remercie merci franck anne
catherine loisier s'excusant nous
passons à alain chatillon puis dominique
estrosi sassone
monsieur le ministre en ce qui concerne
ce qui me concerne je souhaitais vous
faire part de ce que dans les rapports
successifs que j'ai pu faire sur
l'agencé participation de l'état notre
souci était de diversification nous
considérons que depuis des années les
agences de participation de l'état à
concentrer ses moyens sur un certain
nombre d'entreprises
quand on parle de d'entreprises
stratégiques c'était le nucléaire mais
il n'ya pas que le nucléaire qui est
stratégique pour l'état et donc ce que
nous souhaitons c'est qu'il y ait une
ouverture et qu'on n'assiste pas comme
cela s'est passé avec la crise sanitaire
un effondrement de la valorisation de l'
agence des participations de l'état tel
que nous le vivons actuellement
le deuxième point c'est de dire c'est
vrai il y a des diversification
intéressante sur lesquels on aurait pu
avancer un tel cas d' alstom siemens
avec mon collègue socialiste nous avons
fortement essayait martial bourquin de
faire avancer ce dossier
l'europe nous a coincé on ne peut que le
regretter parce que c'était un élément
stratégique très fort et nous pensions
avec le ferroviaire la possibilité
d'alimenter l'hydrogène et faire en
sorte que l'hydrogène soit éléments
forts le troisième élément c'est ait la
possibilité avec d'hydrogène de
rapprocher les potentiels automobile
français et allemand je pense à renault
je pense bien sûr à psa et je pense à
tous ceux qui peuvent être intéressés et
de l'autre côté avec mercedes et bmw
dont vous le voyez je pense que cet
avantage avec l'énergie est la source
d'énergie tels que l'hydrogène
on pouvait attractives sur deux secteurs
importants
notre souci c'est donc qu'on voit sur
l'agencé participation de l'état une
meilleure diversification et un meilleur
engagement car si dominique estrosi
sassone et ensuite jean pierre manga
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais vous poser deux
questions sur les aspects logement et
construction pendant le plf 2021 que
dans le plan de relance parce que vous
le savez le bâtiment est un secteur
essentiel pour notre économie et pour la
reprise d'activité
la construction neuve est la grande
oubliée du plan de relance puisque il y
a 6 7 milliards d'euros qui sont dévolus
à la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
mais rien sur la construction neuve dans
le plan de relance alors votre collègue
ministre du logement a pris apparemment
acte de cette situation et elle a
notamment promis mais on attend toujours
les amendements dans le projet de loi de
finances une prolongation des
dispositifs pinel et ptz devrait savoir
quelle est votre position sur ces
prolongation éventuelle et sur leur
dimension fiscale
et puis concernant le logement social il
ya quelques gestes qui ont été faits ces
dernières semaines je pense en
particulier au maintien de la réduction
de la rls à 1,3 milliard d'euros
mais également à un dispositif qui dans
le plf qui pour créer un abattement
exceptionnelle des plus values
immobilières pour construire des
logements dans le cadre des opération de
revitalisation de territoires ou des
grandes opérations d'urbanisme qui ont
été créés à travers la loi et l'ont donc
je vous pose la question sur d'autres
évolutions qui pourraient elles aussi
favoriser la construction de logements
sociaux et en particulier ce qui touche
à la baisse du taux de tva temps pour
élargir à 500 mètres autour des cuves et
le taux réduit de tva pour l'acquisition
de logements neufs en zone en rue que
pour également d'une façon plus générale
aboutir à un taux de réduit de tva pour
les logements sociaux parce que certes
c'est pas nécessairement décisif quand
on construit un seul logement
par contre salé évidemment extrêmement
important lorsqu'on parle de centaines
ou de milliers de logements qui reste à
construire ou à rénover
merci piles et ensuite laurent duplomb
et ensuite daniel grémillet merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre comme l'année dernière dans le
cadre du plf le gouvernement propose un
nouveau coup de rabot sur le crédit
impôt recherche
ce coup de rabot peut avoir des effets
délétères sur la coopération entre
recherche publique entreprises
je sais que vous aimez parler de
sanctuarisation concernant ce crédit
mais là là je crains que le sanctuaire
soit une fois de plus profanes et plus
sérieusement
ne serait-il pas préférable de reporter
au delà de 2022 cette mesure de rabot
sur le crédit impôt recherche
par ailleurs cette année la ligne
budgétaire finançant les aides à
l'innovation de bpi france est supprimée
et trans fermé et transféré pardon dans
le pays à quatre le soutien aux aidants
ligne à l'innovation versé par bpi
france a fondu comme neige au soleil ces
dernières années j'avais défendu un
amendement contre cette tendance en plf
2020 il m'avait été répondu que bp y
avait un matelas suffisant pour financer
seuls ces aides
je suis donc ravi de constater que le
gouvernement a changé d'avis mais
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que ce
montant sera augmentée toujours à le plf
pour 2021 au titre de la politique de la
ville les maires et les présidents
d'agglomérations sont très inquiet
concernant le risque de la fin de
l'exonération de taxe foncière en
quartiers prioritaires de la ville et
des conséquences qui en découleraient
les propriétaires de locaux commerciaux
dq pv bénéficie depuis cinq ans
d'exonération de taxe foncière sur les
propriétés bâties
celle ci constitue une variable
déterminante pour l' équilibre financier
de leur entreprise surtout dans la
période que nous traversons la fin de
cette exonération entraînerait une
charge financière insupportable qui les
conduirait à cesser leur activité
le plan france relance ne semble pas
aujourd'hui prendre en compte cette une
situation qui concerne de nombreuses
connu communes monsieur le ministre
envisagez vous de prendre en compte dans
le cadre de la loi de finances pour 2011
21 heures un dispositif rectificatif
compensatoires qui permettrait de
proroger ces exonérations fiscales
je vous remercie merci beaucoup laurent
duplomb et daniel grémillet ensuite
monsieur mini jeux vous propose de
répondre à cette première salve de
questions je le ministre madame la
présidente 2638 8 c'est le nom deux
minutes un métier du plan 2638 8 c'est
le nombre de milliards constatait de
notre bête à la fin du premier semestre
2020 beaucoup d'experts parle de 3000
milliards à la fin de cette année
beaucoup disent aussi les taux d'intérêt
sont bas il faut en profiter pour
emprunter il n'en reste pas moins vrai
qu'en bon agriculteur quand on emprunte
nous savons très bien que le bon sens
veut qu'on rembourse cette dette
le remboursement de cette dette de près
de 3000 milliards à la fin de l'année ou
de 2006 138 milliards à fin juin que se
faire monsieur le ministre et vous avez
raison de quatre manières
à mon sens la première c'est par la
croissance l'augmentation de la
croissance
la deuxième ça peut être par l'inflation
mais malheureusement c'est pas le
ministre de l'économie ou heureusement
qu'ils décident de l'inflation par
contre elle peut sert aussi par
l'augmentation des impôts
ma première question monsieur le
ministre c'est est-ce que vous arriverez
à continuer de tenir sur le principe de
ne pas aller sur cette augmentation
d'impôts enfin la quatrième c'est
l'annulation de la dette
beaucoup de nos concitoyens estime parce
qu'ils ont entendu parler pendant des
soupes des années ou des décennies d'une
dette qu on ne remboursera jamais que
nous pourrions peut être annulé cette
dette est la réalité c'est que si nous
allions c'est le dette
nous allons sur une défiance des marchés
et donc par définition une augmentation
et une perte de crédibilité et une
augmentation des prix une perte de
crédibilité de notre pays
alors monsieur le ministre je vous
donnais une solution si vous voulez
augmenter la croissance qui me semble
sur les quatre la seule plausible pour
ne pas avoir beaucoup de monde dans la
rue et des difficultés de gouvernance
c'est qu'il faut que les entreprises
françaises travaillent et je vous
donnerai un exemple avec mon fils nous
investissons 1,2 million d'euros sur une
méthanisation sur ses 1,2 million
d'euros
nous aurons nous aurons donné deux cent
mille euros à des entreprises françaises
que le million restant cds allemands
quand le processus c'est des roumains
qui ont construit les fausses la semaine
où on interdisait à nos enfants de
passer le brevet des collèges
c'est des tchèques pu remonter le
système c'est des hongrois les
ukrainiens c'est fini ddd hollandais qui
ont fait le transport pas un français
donc monsieur le ministre si on veut
véritablement faire de la croissance il
faut faire travailler nos entreprises
merci il faut comprendre d'exercice et
daniel grémillet pour terminer cette
première salve oui merci main présente
monsieur le ministre
3 trois questions la première je vais
très bref c'est l'hydrogène puisqu'elle
a déjà été abordé dans le plan de
relance les ambitions celui de rouge n
alors que c'est un dossier absolument
stratégique
si on veut notre indépendance et
retrouver des capacités
de compétitivité on n'est pas à la
hauteur par rapport à nos à des
collègues au sein de l'union européenne
à d'autres pays qui sont bien plus
ambitieux et bien sûr lorsqu'on se
compare aussi à l'asie donc comment
imaginez vous un plan de relance
hydrolats et hydrogène qui donne des
chances à l'économie française
deuxième point sur la forêt on n'est pas
au rendez vous sur ministre quand on
voit 200 millions sur le dossier
forestier et compte au roi la souffrance
et l'enjeu pour l'économie pour le
climat là encore comment pensez-vous
réagir face à cette absence de capacité
financière sur dossier forestier le
dernier point je voulais évoquer
concerne la rénovation énergétique vous
l'avez très bien dit je partage votre
propos il ya un vrai succès et je
partage aussi ce qu'a dit à notre
collègue dominique estrosi sassone parce
que on a là des rénovations mais on a
une absence complète au niveau du neuf
ma question et les sur le travail
sénatorial
dans un amendement le sénat et ça a été
repris par l'assemblée a dit tout
simplement
dès lors qu'on est sur l'argent public
c'est quand même dommage que cet argent
public qui va à l'accompagnement sur la
rénovation puissent bénéficier plus tôt
à des entreprises et du matériel qui ne
vient pas de france qui vient pas
d'europe mais qui vient parfois
d'ailleurs comment repositionner la
relocalisation
avec ce plan de relance et je terminerai
tout simplement en disant monsieur le
ministre je partage vos idées seule la
croissance nous permettra de retrouver
une capacité à rembourser la dette
sauf que je crains qu'il y ait un
décalage au niveau du rendez vous par
rapport au calendrier vous avez imaginé
les entreprises ne seront pas même si
vous avez donné un an de report ne
seront pas en capacité de le faire aussi
rapidement
merci daniel monsieur le ministre je
propose de répondre à cette première
partie de questions merci madame la
présidente
alain larcher sur l'urgence économique
je redis que tous les dispositifs que
nous avons mis en place font solidarité
adaptation du prêt garanti par l'état
exonération de charges doivent nous
permettre de remédier d'urgence
économique et que les mesures
d'augmentation l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire et 150 euros de primes pour les
bénéficiaires de l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique du revenu de
solidarité active peuvent aussi
permettre d'apporter du soutien à ceux
de nos compatriotes qui ont les niveaux
de revenus les plus faibles soient
décarbonation et la numérisation
j'ai entendu les critiques elles étaient
tout à fait fondés toutes les critiques
que fondées elles sont constructives et
est utile a expliqué qu'il y avait trop
de dispositif trop de guichet c'était
vrai j'ai vu qu'il ya une multiplication
de guichet tous azimuts
chacun est parfaitement légitime mais au
bout du compte ça complique les choses
donc il y aura un guichet unique pour la
décarbonation et la digitalisation des
pme en france qui permettra à une pme
qui veut se digitalise et elle va
acheter un logiciel dont elle a besoin
pour la digitalisation de son entreprise
ou son commerce et sur simple
présentation de la facture elle aura
droit à une réduction d'impôt de 40%
donc on aura une aide directe qui sera
apportée pour la digitalisation via un
guichet unique sur les cci et ça permet
de répondre aussi à la question de serge
babary fois encore je pense vraiment que
nous sommes dans un temps où il faut
pratiquer le dialogue et l'écouté c'est
une vertu que vous pratiquez tous
puisque d'autres responsables politiques
mais je pense qu'elle est encore plus
nécessaire en période de crise donc j'ai
entendu les craintes des cci qui m'ont
dit voilà vous avez demandé de faire des
économies et de réduire le montant de la
taxe affectée de manière très
significative nous aviez dit il ya une
clause de revoyure
si la situation économique se détériore
il faudra corriger les chiffres on a
corrigé les chiffres nous avons trouvé
un accord avec les cci et je me félicite
que cet accord qui prévoit la baisse du
plafond de ressources affectées limité à
50 millions d'euros
en 2022
et une stabilisation du niveau de
ressources affectées au cci en 2021 par
rapport à la loi de finances initiale
pour 2020 soit un plafond de 349
millions d'euros pour la taxe
additionnelle au lieu des 2 149 qui
avait été prévu 600 millions d'euros qui
sont rendus par rapport à la trajectoire
initiale ou cci et été acceptée par les
cci et adoptée à l'unanimité l'assemblée
nationale je crois que c'est vraiment un
cas d'école de ce dialogue qui permet de
parvenir au bout du compte à des
solutions qui correspondent à l'intérêt
général
enfin ce que je suis trop optimiste je
pense on est jamais trop optimiste quand
on est mise et l'économie et des
finances par ailleurs j'ai été prudent
dans mes estimations souvenez vous début
septembre tout d'un coup tout le monde
s'est enflammé en disant ça y est la
croissance redémarre sa 28 07 % de
récession chiffres de la banque de
france
ça va être un peu moins de neuf chiffres
de l' ocde
d'autres chiffres avancés par l'insee
tout le monde m'a dit mais révise le
chiffre de croissance de récession de
-11 à moins 9
safra choc de confiance j'ai eu comme
réponse très prudente que les risques de
retour la pandémie était réel les
risques internationaux étaient
considérables et donc nous ne révise
aurions pas la récession au delà de -10
donc j'ai maintenu le chiffre de - 10 je
crois que cette prudence
elle est un facteur de confiance pour
les français mais si on commence tous
les quatre matins a dit à cette
effroyable puis le lendemain en fait
c'est formidable non on va passer par
des hauts et par débat par des moments
où ce sera encore plus dur
des moments où on compterait à
l'économie va redémarrer moi je crois
profondément que la trajectoire sur le
long terme ce sera les difficultés
actuelles qui sont très durs pour des
millions de nos compatriotes
la poursuite de ces difficultés tant que
le virus sera là faut être lucide là
dessus des entreprises qui effectivement
au bout du compte ne pourront pas tenir
mais aussi d'ici deux ans d'autres
secteurs qui vont ouvrir d'autres
entreprises qui vont ouvrir d'autres
industries qui vont se créer je pense
par exemple aux batteries électriques à
douvrin dans le nord pour donner un
exemple très concret je pense à
l'hydrogène qui permettront à la france
au bout du compte de surmonter cette
épreuve
moi j'ai confiance dans la france et
dans les français pour surmonter
cette épreuve qui est dur mais pour
laquelle nous sommes équipés pour faire
face
serge babary je vous ai répondu sur
l'essai c'est peut être un petit mot sur
commerce artisanat pour rappeler que
celle agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires sous l'autorité de
jacqueline gourault qui désormais gère
cela est rappelé également un projet qui
malheureusement n'est pas assez connu
alors qu'il est pour moi absolument
vital c'est les fonctionnaires qui sont
créés par la banque des territoires sous
l'autorité de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations il ya 6000 foncière
j'espère qu'on pourra le porter à 10
milles qui prennent des locaux
commerciaux en centre ville
l'airé noble et rachète les rendent
énergétiquement plus compétitifs les
rassemble ça permet d'avoir un commerce
de plus grande taille et ensuite les
loups un tarif préférentiel
on a mis plusieurs milliards d'euros sur
cette opération
donc je souhaite qu'elle soit connue de
toutes les villes moyennes et de toutes
les petites communes et que le plus
grand nombre puisse en bénéficier je
pense que c'est extrêmement efficace
simple au bénéfice des villes moyennes
et des petites villes mais le dispositif
n'est pas assez connue donc je profite
de votre question pour rappeler qu'il
existe
franck montaugé sur la relocalisation
des plans structure et oui il y aura des
plans structuré il y a déjà des plans
structurés notamment pour l'aéronautique
ou pour l'automobile j'ai entendu les
critiques sur les donneurs d'ordre du
secteur aérien du secteur aéronautique
je les ai tous rassemblés il y a
quelques jours pour les rappeler à leurs
responsabilités de donneur d'ordre et
comme nous n'arrivons pas à nous mettre
d'accord sur l'évaluation des relations
entre les donneurs d'ordre dassault
thales safran et airbus par rapport aux
sous traitants mais que bois j'ai pas de
raison de croire les uns plus tôt que
les autres
nous avons mis en place un suivi
régulier avec un observateur indépendant
qui doit nous permettre de repérer très
exactement difficulté territoire par
territoire
alain chatillon m'avait aussi à alerter
sur ce sujet large c'est que c'est une
préoccupation dans son territoire mais
nous assurons le suivi régulier de la
charte du gifas qui s'est engagé à
respecter notamment les délais de
paiement et le bon traitement
sous traitants il reste beaucoup de
travail à faire sur ce sujet je voulais
parfaite conscience je les dis encore
récemment
enfin sur le soutien en fonds propres
des entreprises
oui toutes les entreprises ne pourront
pas bénéficier de fonds propres et de
prêts participatifs
on m'avait demandé d'avoir une garantie
de l'état à 100% comme toujours je suis
totalement transparent j'ai refusé qu'il
est une garantie de l'état 100% et je
demandé que les bandes porte au moins 10
% du risque pourquoi ce que sinon si les
banques sont pas exposés au risque elles
vont soutenir n'importe quelle
entreprise sans critères éthiques paiera
au bout du compte le contribuable je
pense qu'il faut partager les risques et
il est important que dans ces prêts
participatifs les banques portent 10 %
du risque total
alain chatillon ashton simen je les
portais j'ai regretté la décision de la
commission européenne
mais on peut aussi se réjouir quand même
du projet entre alstom et bombardier
parce que ça prouve que nous avons des
industries qui sont puissantes et qui
peuvent opérer des fusions et des
rassemblements sur la base de leurs
compétences et de leur savoir-faire
japon également à votre question sur
l'hydrogène et je fais le saut avec la
question de daniel gamme il est l'un des
enjeux très importants de cette relance
à mon sens c'est que comme toute crise
ça puisse être une opportunité pour
ouvrir de nouveaux champs d'excellence
français nous nous sommes endormis sur
nos lauriers pas se voiler la face c'est
dit le luxe c'est formidable les vins
c'est formidable agroalimentaire c'est
formidable l'aéronautique c'est
formidable le médicament c'est
formidable et puis on va vivre comme ça
pendant encore 50 ans avec les mêmes
d'entreprise et les mêmes champions
industriels
comprenez-moi bien à ces champions
industriels sont une fierté nationale
ils réussissent très bien tant mieux
simplement quand tout d'un coup vous
avez des taxes sur le vin français et un
effondrement du secteur aéronautique
vous avez deux nouveaux moteurs qui sont
touchés de plein fouet je pense qu'il
est bon d'avoir d'autres moteurs et de
participer à l'économie du 20e
en se contentant pas de vie sur nos
acquis du 20e siècle
il faut que nous construisions les
succès industriels français du 21e
siècle
l'hydrogène est un des secteurs sur
lequel nous avons décidé d'investir
massivement et je viens d'expliquer sur
quoi nous avons décidé d'investir ce que
les choix ans et est long difficile et
je pense qu'il est important que la
représentation nationale soient
parfaitement informés
il y avait une solution de facilité qui
était de dire ce qui compte par dessus
tout c'est la réduction immédiate des
émissions de co2 et la consommation
d'hydrogène donc on aurait pu faire
comme sur les panneaux photovoltaïques
financées les tarif préférentiel d'achat
d'hydrogène en un an ou deux on aurait
développé rapidement la consommation
d'hydrogène en france nous ne nions pas
été producteur d'hydrogène nous avons
fait avec le président républicain choix
totalement différent qui est plus long
plus rentable sur le long terme et
garant de notre souveraineté
nous allons produire nous mêmes en
france
de l'hydrogène vert et donc nous allons
investir dans toutes les briques
industriels du secteur industriel de
l'hydrogène selon investir dans les
réservoirs d'eau ont déjà des champions
avec faurecia par exemple sur ce domaine
la zone loin nerfs investir dans les
piles à combustible nous allons investir
dans des électrolyseurs je peux pas vous
dire encore quelle sera la technologie
c'est très complexe et technologie de
membrane qui sont très prometteuses mais
qui sont très coûteuses mais nous
pouvons avoir en france d'ici quelques
années une giga factory de production
d'hydrogène qui sera la plus importante
au monde
c'est possible c'est à portée de main et
je vois pas pourquoi on se priverait de
cette ambition industrielle
ce à quoi nous avions décidé de nous
lancer dans le nucléaire personne
n'imaginait que deviendrions un des
meilleurs spécialistes la production
d'énergie nucléaire civil au monde
nous le sommes devenus quand on sait
d'anciens aventure airbus il n'y a pas
grand monde qui pensait que l'europe
parviendrait à voir le constructeur
d'avions le plus rentable le plus
performant technologiquement le plus
pointu de la planète nous y sommes
arrivés
bg vous donner ma conviction va y
arriver aussi pour l'hydrogène et je
pense que l'europe peut-être l'un des
continents les plus performants sur la
production et la consommation
d'hydrogène dans les années à venir
mais cela suppose des investissements
massifs 7 milliards d'euros
et ça suppose effectivement une
coopération franco allemande
nous en avons discuté autour du
président de la république et de la
chancelière
il ya quelques jours et je peux vous
dire que les projets de coopération
franco allemand sur l'hydrogène avance à
très bon pas on a simplement une
différence que vous connaissez tous
c'est que nous nous estimons que
l'électricité considérable qui est
nécessaire pour faire fonctionner les
électrolyseurs à partir du moment où
s'est décrite et nucléaire elle est
verte parce qu'elle émet peu de co2 là
où les allemands estiment que la
production par l'électricité nucléaire
pose une difficulté mais c'est le seul
problème que nous ayons tous les autres
sont en voie de résolution et nous
permettent d'avancer rapidement
dominique estrosi ce n'est pas un petit
problème je ne dis pas ça mais dominique
estrosi sassone sur la construction
neuve où on a effectivement un sujet
important qui m'était souligné par
beaucoup de monde j'ai participé au
congrès de la fédération du bâtiment il
y a quelques jours il ya une
concertation en cours avec l'ensemble du
secteur concerné que le bâtiment
les promoteurs les travaux publics pour
améliorer l'efficacité du pinède et du
ptz
on doit tenir compte des enjeux qui sont
soulevées par la convention citoyenne
sur le climat notamment la question de
l'artificialisation des sols est un vrai
sujet je sais que vous y êtes sensibles
en tout état de cause les dispositifs
seront prolongées parce qu'ils sont
nécessaires pour soutenir la
construction neuve et nous aurons une
discussion avec la parlement ce cette
question de l'artificialisation qui
n'est pas une question simple mais qui
est absolument vital pour nos
territoires
je suis moi même et lui d'un territoire
rural et j'ai vu dans l'eure à quel
point cette extension illimitée des
zones pavillonnaires pose un problème
environnemental absolument majeur
même temps une attente dont compatriotes
sur le logement individuel
donc il y à des choix économiques à
faire il ya aussi une évolution
culturelle a engagé qui n'est pas
forcément la plus simple jean pierre
moga sur l'ajustement du cir je vais
être très clair sur ce sujet là comme je
l'espère sur tous les autres sujets très
franchement si j'avais pu éviter de
toucher au crédit impôt recherche je
l'aurais fait moi je suis pour la
stabilité fiscale ou la baisse des
impôts pour répondre à laurent duplomb
mon touch aux impôts
mieux on se porte le traficotage
permanent des impôts de donne rien de
bon donc sur le crédit impôt recherche
on a simplement un problème de mise en
conformité avec l'union européenne
et si je n'avais pas fait cette mise en
conformité
nous courions le risque que le principe
même du crédit impôt recherche fasse
l'objet d'un recours juridique et d'une
décision juridictionnelle qui aurait été
très pénalisante pour nous donc c'est
pour cela que nous vous proposons cet
ajustement du crédit impôt recherche
c'est vraiment pour des raisons de mise
en conformité avec le droit européen
je vous confirme que globalement les
crédits à la recherche augmenteront et
que je suis très attaché à ce crédit
impôt recherche qui ai fait la preuve de
son efficacité
laurent duplomb pose une question
fondamentale à laquelle je veux répondre
avec beaucoup de fermeté
tant que je serai ministre des finances
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts
sur les français dans notre pays tout
simplement parce qu'il ya toujours plein
de justification pour augmenter les
impôts
chaque fois il ya une très bonne
proposition en disant il faut taxer ceux
ci taxes et cela impose et les plus
riches imposer de 1% ceux ci imposé 2 %
cela mais je rappelle juste une chose
simple
nous sommes le pays développés qui a le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires le
plus élevé au monde
c'est tout donc partant de ce
raisonnement qui peut être un peu court
un peu basique et je m'en excuse auprès
de vous mon ma responsabilité n'est pas
d'essayer de battre le record du taux
d'imposition mondial a déjà battu ma
responsabilité c'est de stabiliser des
impôts ou de les baisser c'est ce que
nous faisons avec 22 milliards d'euros
de baisses d'impôts sur les ménages et
22 milliards d'euros 2
impôts sur les entreprises depuis 2010
est enfin sur la dette vous avez
parfaitement raison
moi j'invite chacun à faire preuve de
sens des responsabilités vous avez tous
ici une part du pouvoir législatif
expliquer qu'on va annuler la dette
s'est créé beaucoup de défiance chez les
investisseurs
un investisseur à qui on propose
d'acheter des bons du trésor si on lui
explique attendez je ne vous inquiétez
pas ça vous sera jamais remboursée et
vous ne toucherez pas d'argent avec ça
je doute qu'on arrive à lever facilement
de la dette avec ce genre de discours
donc oui la dette devrait être remboursé
où il devra l'est pas la croissance
et oui il faut faire travailler nos
entreprises daniel grémillet c'est
hydrogène je crois avoir répondu sur le
domaine forestier depuis je ne suis plus
ministre l'agriculture
j'avoue ma moindre connaissance du sujet
donc on vous fera cher daniel une
réponse personnalisée sur le sujet enfin
la rénovation énergétique vous touchez
du doigt des points très importants il
faut que ça évite donc nous nous
réservons le droit avec le premier
ministre de réaffecter des crédits pour
des projets qu'ils n'iraient pas
suffisamment vite et il est essentiel
mais le bâtiment s'y est engagée que le
secteur du bâtiment se forment dispose
davantage d'entreprises qui bénéficient
de la certification énergétique pour que
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
profite aux entreprises françaises
merci monsieur le ministre alors j'ai un
petit dylan c'est que j'ai 14 inscrits
aux questions voilà il vous reste 25
minutes donc ce que je vous propose en
fait mes chers collègues c'est de poser
vos questions extrêmement rapidement
et puis le ministre pourra peut-être
commencer à répondre et peut-être finira
par répondre par écrit peut-être à
l'ensemble de nos collègues qui n'auront
pas posé de questions la parole est à
jean marie jeanne scène juste avant de
avant ça je voudrais quand même dire au
ministre de l'économie que vous est cher
bruno le maire que moi j'ai compris dans
la conscience citoyenne qui avait quand
même quelques augmentations d'impôts
donc voilà je sais pas comment vous
aurez ce débat là est ce sujet-là au
gouvernement mais en tout cas j'ai
compris dans cette convention citoyenne
qui en avait beaucoup
jean-marie jeune scène ensuite catherine
fournier la crise sanitaire et
économique ce qui frappe notre pays
depuis plusieurs mois à des conséquences
extrêmement graves sur l'emploi et la
survie de plusieurs branches d'activité
professionnelle
c'est le cas dans le secteur
aéronautique particulièrement touché à
tous les échelons les compagnies
aériennes les grands constructeurs
aéronautiques et leurs soins traitants
sont en proie aux plus grandes
difficultés
ainsi dans mon département de loir et
cher l'entreprise daher a annoncé un
vaste plan de restructuration menaçant
de centaines d'emplois dans des deux
sites du val de cher à saint julien de
chaindon et montrichard
de même le groupe thales se prépare à
supprimer des postes sur les deux sites
de vendôme
les conséquences sur l'emploi local sont
là aussi extrêmement préoccupante malgré
un plan de relance pour l'aéronautique à
hauteur de 15 milliards d'euros annoncé
par gouvernement cet été
les suppressions de postes sont là et
les perspectives de reprise nous laisse
très pessimiste soutenir et relancer la
filière aéronautique commence par
sécuriser les investissements
industriels du secteur et l'emploi local
il est essentiel de donner des
entreprises comme daher de la visibilité
et des éléments concrets de soutien pour
les aider à prendre les bonnes décisions
à faire les bons choix stratégiques et
ne pas s'engager dans une
restructuration trop lourde sur le plan
de l'emploi
ainsi au delà des aides financières
monsieur le maire
pouvez vous nous présenter les mesures
que le gouvernement entend prendre pour
défendre et préserver l'emploi local
dans ce secteur aéronautique
merci merci beaucoup jean marie
catherine fournit ensuite fabien gay oui
même la présidente merci merci monsieur
le ministre je reviendrai sur le soutien
aux tpe pme
au delà du plf 2021 je ne suis pas
rassuré est persuadé que les tpe pme
bénéficieront bien et correctement de la
relance ne faudrait-il
un réel choc de simplification des
procédures administratives pour que ce
plan trouve l'efficacité affiché c'était
pe pme n'ont pas souvent les services
internes et madame la présidente l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure qui leur
permettent de mener à bien les démarches
pour cibler les aides adaptées elles ont
du mal à les identifier à connaître
l'interlocuteur verts qui s'orientait
ensuite réunir les pièces demandées
souvent disproportionnés par rapport aux
et date attendue est souvent aucun délai
n'engage l'administration qui en a la
charge en othe france pour vous donner
un exemple il a été décidé de monter un
guichet unique où il y aura un
interlocuteur qui dispatche khaled et le
la réponse sera donnée sous le délai
d'un mois
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de petites de
tpe tpe pme qui justement se perdent
dans le tous ces méandres et qui
abandonnent les dossiers parce qu'elle
ne se dise on n'y arrivera jamais on
passe trop de temps et d'énergie
pourquoi également monsieur le ministre
avoir opté pour une baisse de la cvae
qui n'est pas l'impôt de production qui
touchent le plus directement les tpe pme
pour permettre la solvabilité des
entreprises
n'aurait-il pas été plus efficace de
maintenir les aides temporaires à
destination de ces entreprises c'est à
dire les baisses ou annulations de
cotisations sociales ou d'impôts c'était
me semble-t-il un moyen plus simple et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure direct
d'atteindre l'objectif souhaité qui est
de venir en aide aux entreprises
merci monsieur le ministre merci
catherine fabien gay ensuite valérie
létard oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur oui je regrette qu'on n'ait pas
le temps parce que pour le coup je vais
poser deux questions et je voudrais pas
mordre le trait
ce que je pense que si on avait un débat
je pourrais vous dire que je suis en
accord avec un certain nombre de mesures
pas tout évidemment on a un débat mais
par exemple sur les prêts garantis par
l'état notamment pour les petits
commerçants et aux artisans je pense que
c'est une vraie question
je pense qu'il faudra les convertir en
fonds propres ce qui quand ils vont se
retrouver face au mur de la dette en
mars
je pense que ça va être compliqué pareil
la même chose que sur le fond de
solidarité
et là aussi avec serge est un
on avait fait un rapport ou demandions
de le prolonger jusqu'au 31 décembre
potentiellement jusqu'au 31 juin
donc j'en viens j'ai deux questions mais
qui vont faire débat là pour le coup
vous aviez dit premièrement pendant la
crise j'appelle les entreprises surtout
les grandes à modérer leurs dividendes
franchement je vais vous dire c'est un
échec
ce que 100 % des entreprises du cac 40
ont été les seuls chômage partiel pge
deux tiers d'entre elles ont versé des
dividendes et huit d'entre elles ont
augmenté leurs dividendes par rapport à
l'année d'avant
alors je sais vous allez me dire oui
mais c'est sûr 2019
donc je vous pose une question est ce
qu'en 2021 sur l'exercice 2020 on va
légiférer pour interdire le versement de
dividendes aux actionnaires
c'est une question celle qui ont été
aidées celles qui ont été aidés comme
vous le souhaitiez la deuxième question
et j'en viens vous voyez je serai pas
plus long c'est un petit schéma là et
vous rappeler monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi montre le schéma c'était sur
twitter c'est vous qui l'avez partager
avec jean castex
il y avait suivi rigoureux c'est bon
c'est tout en haut il faut le regarder
ça veut dire quoi parce que vous avez un
débat chez les salariés c'est qu'ils
voient tomber des aides publiques à gogo
et ils subissent les plans de
licenciements donc la question qui est
posée c'est vous voulez pas conditionner
les aides publiques et les critéres ise
en termes d'emploi environnement
recherche et développement mais est-ce
que vous allez quel plan de suivi celles
et ceux qui auront pas respecté est ce
qu'il y aura sanction pas c'est une
question
et dernière chose ouais je pense qu'on
aura un petit les mains mais pas
aujourd'hui mais je vois qu'on dit
alstom bombardier et ses jeux pour qu'on
regarde de près ce qui vient de se
passer
suez veolia quand même avec angie je me
rappelle bien le débat de la loi pacte
qu'on avait eue ensemble on n'était pas
nombreux à voter contre
et vous nous aviez expliqué monsieur le
ministre qui aurait jamais de problème
parce que l'etat sera actionnaire
majoritaire et qu'il aurait la golden
share
mais on a vu c'était un peu plus
compliqué que ce qu'on nous avait
raconté pendant la loi pope
merci
merci fabien valérie létard ensuite joël
labbé oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre
étant donné l'impact du logement et de
la construction sur la dynamique
économique au moment où nous sommes en
train de parler du plan de relance soit
je souhait de vous poser de questions
sur action logement questions auxquelles
j'associe mes collègues dominique
estrosi sassone viviane artigalas et
marie noëlle lienemann co rapporteur a
avec moi de la mission d'information de
la commission sur la réforme d'action
logement et de l'apec les prélèvements
logement le journal le monde et d'autres
médias ont eu communication du rapport
de l'inspection générale des finances
sur action logement alors que nous
parlementaires ne l'avons toujours pas
il est pourtant essentiel pour
comprendre ce qui se passe depuis
plusieurs mois autour de cet organisme
paritaire et assurer la pleine
information du parlement une réforme
étant envisagées dans le projet de loi
de finances comment débattre et décider
sur un sujet aussi important sans avoir
tous les éléments monsieur le ministre
le parlement a eu communication des
rapports de la cour des comptes et de
lampaul ce monsieur le ministre quand
vous transmettrez vous ce rapport doligé
f et deuxième question vous avez fait
part à l'assemblée nationale de votre
intention de mener à bien la réforme
d'action logement en même temps que
celle des retraites
monsieur olivier dussopt pts a indiqué
que le gouvernement déposerait un
amendement pour l'autoriser à procéder à
cette réforme par ordonnance pouvez vous
nous confirmer ces informations et le
calendrier
pouvez vous nous préciser les
informations du gouvernement en la
matière et j'en profite pour vous
demander si vous pouvez répondre à la
question de monsieur maugard puisque j'y
suis sensible comme adam estrosi sassone
sur les exonérations de tfpb leur
possible prorogation pour les locaux
commerciaux en quartiers politique de la
ville je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
valérie létard la parole est à joël
labbé ensuite à daniel laurent nous
parler de vin versés madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre merci de
votre présentation
parmi les immenses défis que vous avez à
relever il y a aussi le verdissement
nécessaire du budget via la méthode
budget vert il est maintenant enfin
possible d'avoir une vision claire et
transparente des niches fiscales néfaste
pour les climats et des subventions aux
énergies fossiles
le rapport du gouvernement sur l'impact
environnemental du pl incite les
dépenses fiscales défavorables pour
l'environnement il chiffre les exclus
les exonérations ou taux réduit sur les
thijs et des produits énergétiques
relatifs aux carburants ce à 5,1
milliards d'euros
cependant le rapport de la commission du
trésor et du ministère de la transition
écologique de l'année dernière le green
budgeting annonçait 12,2 milliards
d'euros et la commission européenne
le chiffre est à 9 7 milliards d'euros
les différences s'expliquent par le
choix du périmètre et cet intérim at
large et complet qui doit permettre
d'avoir une vue globale afin d'engager
une trajectoire de suppression tout en
accompagnant les secteurs concernés
alors monsieur le ministre envisagez
vous dans l'antre dans un futur proche
de nous donner cette vision globale et
de rectifier ces chiffres jour merci
merci je vais lui donner la parole à
daniel auront ensuite je donnerai la
parole au ministre qui répondent à ces
questions et ensuite on verra le temps
qui nous reste
malheureusement oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je vais concentrer
mon propos sur la filière viticole
durement touché par la crise sanitaire
d'autant plus qu'elle affrontait
concomitamment les sanctions américaines
le bric cite la crise de hong kong avec
une impact très importantes sur les
exportations l'om c'est vient
d'autoriser l'union européenne à
appliquer des sanctions tarifaires d'un
montant de 4 milliards de dollars à
l'encontre de produits et services
américains dans le dossier des aides
américaines à boeing
quant à la prochaine liste des produits
taxés par les états unis
elles devraient être communiqués plus
tard en février prochain les
représentants des producteurs et des
distributeurs de spiritueux renouvellent
leur demande de retirer les vins et
spiritueux de la liste et demandent une
intensification des efforts pour aboutir
une solution négociée
en effet la décision de l'om sait
risque de crisper un peu plus les
amériques comment trouver un équilibre
dans son rapport de force afin qu ils ne
pénalisent pas davantage nos entreprises
et les emplois la baisse de valeur des
importations des etats-unis a dépassé
les 500 millions d'euros en dix mois
alors que 30% de notre économie dépend
des échanges internationaux
la partie export du plan de relance qui
représente 247 millions tous secteurs
confondus et l proportionnée jeune
ministre vous déclariez le 15 octobre
mais encore tout à l'heure dernier que
la cave de la france compterait compter
trois grandes free filière
l'aéronautique le luxe les vins et les
spiritueux et vous disiez tout à l'heure
il faut avoir d'autres moteurs c'est
bien mais d'autres moteurs c'est bien
mais conservant d'abord ce qui existe
depuis le gouvernement a mis en place
depuis plusieurs plans sectoriels
l'aéronautique l'automobile
indispensable bien sûr en revanche
aucune mesure de cette nature pour le
secteur des vins et spiritueux qui
pourrait être une fois de plus la
victime collatérale d'un contentieux
auxquels il est totalement étranger
quelles réponses pouvez vous leur
apportez le plan de relance ou
tiendra-t-il cette filière merci
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse
répondre et je voudrais dire à daniel
salmon martin berthet yves bouloux
franck mélange ville sylvia noël et
michel bonnus comprendre à leurs
questions et qu'on les transmettra au
ministre de l'économie je suis désolé et
voilà on doit répondre aux contraintes
des uns et des autres merci beaucoup
madame la présidente je répondrais
évidemment par écrit aux questions qui
n'ont pas pu être posées pour des
raisons de contraintes horaires mais je
préfère répondre à ces questions qui
sont des questions majeures
jean-marie d'une scène sur les
compagnies aériennes et sur le secteur
aéronautique de manière générale
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
l'ensemble de l'économie française
les emplois qui sont les plus touchés
sont les emplois de services à faible
qualification et il faut bien mesurer à
quel point je le redis les intérimaires
les personnes peu qualifiées
les contrats courts ont été les
premières victimes de la crise
ce qui explique aussi les dispositifs
que nous avons mis en place mais ensuite
quand on regarde les secteurs qui sont
touchés c'est extraordinairement
variable les deux secteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont les plus touchées
directement par la crise c'est tout ce
qui est est ce un ace un bis pour faire
dans la technique c'est-à-dire
hôtellerie cafés restauration
événementielle culture spectacle vivant
salle de sport et le transport air
transport aérien c'est une chute comme
il n'en a pas connu depuis la création
du transport aérien avec des
perspectives qui malheureusement sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement incertaines donc
l'effet sur les sous-traitants
aéronautiques comme d'air ou d'autres
et d'ailleurs est un gros sous-traitants
sont absolument considérable donc nous
avons mis en place ce fonds de soutien
nous avons mis en place un fonds
d'investissement pour très concrètement
occupé des ingénieurs ce que avoir un
ingénieur aéronautique qui disparaît
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ça
coûts considérables pour l'ensemble de
la société c'est un coût humain c'est un
coup technologique
j'ai parfaitement conscience de ce qui
se passe chez daher chez thales à
vendôme j'ai reçu des présents de thales
il ya quelques jours pour discuter avec
lui on cherche à chaque fois les
meilleures solutions
l'accord qui était conclu chez airbus
je tiens à féliciter les salariés les
représentants syndicaux la direction
d'airbus
parce qu'on a évité c'était la ligne
avait fixé le gouvernement
on à éviter les licenciements secs mais
c'est des semaines de négociations et au
bout du compte je tiens à le dire des
efforts très importants qui sont
demandés aux salariés
mais pardon de le dire avec beaucoup
d'humilité
nous n'avons pas le choix si on veut que
le secteur aéronautique sont sortis et
des efforts qui sont à faire absolument
partout tout simplement parce que les
avions ne volent plus que le transport
aérien a chuté au cours des dernières
semaines et je le redis des perspectives
sont très incertaines
je veux insister aussi sur le fait que
l'état prend toute sa part
quand jeudi un plan à des huit milliards
c'est milliards ne veulent plus dire
grand chose pour qui que ce soit mais ça
veut dire très concrètement que nous
finançons
le surcoût des commandes aérienne qui
seraient annulés si l'état ne supportait
pas la garantie financière de ses
commandes pourraient tout à fait concret
quand les émirats arabes unis qui
commandent des a380 guise isma ses a380
ont pu servir à grand chose parce qu'il
ya plus de transport aérien en tout cas
plus le même volume
nous nous payons pour que les commandes
soient maintenues la garantie export
soit maintenue sur un an ou deux ans
supplémentaires
et ça se chiffre en milliards d'euros
pas an centaines de millions en
milliards d'euros
donc tout le monde fait sa part du
chemin pour essayer de préserver un
secteur dont les compétences
technologiques ne se retrouveront pas si
nous les perdons mais je vais pas vous
le cacher
ça va être dur c'est un des secteurs qui
les plus fragilisées aujourd'hui c'est
un secteur d'excellence nous ferons tout
ce qui est en notre pouvoir
absolument tout pour sauver le maximum
d'emplois et le maximum d'entreprises
catherine fournier sur le choc de
simplification je partage totalement
c'est pas 50 ans dans une plate de crise
parce que tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit
la complexité des dispositifs qui sont
supportables en période ordinaire mais
insupportable en période de crise donc
nous avons pris un certain nombre de
décisions et nous sommes prêts à aller
encore plus loin notamment dans le cadre
de la loi a zappé nous avons mis en
place effectivement un guichet unique
pour la digitalisation des pme nous
avons modifié les règles des appels
d'offres pour les contrats publics
je rappelle que jusqu'à présent pour un
contrat de travaux publics jusqu'à 40000
euros
il fallait au delà de quarante mille
euros un appel d'offres vont remonter le
seuil à 100000 euros
ça va permettre de faire pas mal de
petits travaux dans les petites communes
tout cas pour les petites communes
ça va être un soulagement on considère
un peu engagé des travaux publics
jusqu'à 100000 euros sans appel d'offres
nous avons demandé un raccourcissement
des délais administratifs également et
nous allons poursuivre une fois encore
dans cette voie de la simplification sur
la baisse des coûts de production chez a
quand même à rappeler que les premiers
bénéficiaires en valeur relative vont
être les pme puisqu'elle représente 25%
de la valeur ajoutée globale du pays
mais elles vont bénéficier à 30% de
cette baisse des
pardon des impôts de production donc on
est très vigilants à ce que les pme
soient bénéficiaires de ces choix que
nous faisons en matière économique
fabien gay trois questions importantes
d'abord sur la modération des dividendes
j'ai fixé une règle pour les grandes
entreprises qui est que toute entreprise
d'une taille significative qui
bénéficient de l'aide directe de l'état
soit sous forme de pge soit sous forme
d'exonérations de charges ne peut pas
verser de dividende
donc qu'est les recommandations globale
et il ya les obligations donc une grande
entreprise qui demande à l'état un prêt
à le demande à la banque un prêt mais ce
prêt est garanti par l'état ne peut pas
verser de dividende
si vous n'avez pas suffisamment d'argent
pour votre trésorerie n'est pas
suffisamment d'argent pour vos
actionnaires et cette règle j'avais fait
respecté puisqu'il m'est arrivé de
refuser des prêts garantis par l'état
des entreprises qui avaient versé des
dividendes
bonjour et libre se dé trouver de
l'argent pour leurs actionnaires vous
n'avez pas demandé de l'argent garanties
par l'état
la question qui va se poser je vous dis
très simplement et comme toujours en
parfaite transparence
la réalité de la situation c'est à
partir du moment où une prolongation du
prêt garanti par l'état puisque j'ai
décidé de reporter la possibilité de
demander un pg e du 31 décembre 2020 au
30 juin 2021
on a donc six mois supplémentaires pour
demander un pg e s que nous reconduisons
cette règle pour les plus grandes
entreprises je suis évidemment favorable
à ce qu'on reconduit cette règle et de
grandes entreprises qui demanderait en
janvier ou en février réhab on demande
son péché eux dans ce cas là la
condition c'est qu'elle ne peut pas
verser de dividende
je rappelle également que toute
entreprise qui est installé dans les
paradis fiscaux ne peut bénéficier
d'aucune aide de la part de l'état sur
la conditionnalité des aides se tient à
rappeler que la plupart des z qui sont
versées sont déjà conditionnés en
réalité si vous voulez toucher la prime
pour l'embauché d'un jeune apprenti il
faut embaucher un apprenti
si vous des bénéfices
des avantages fiscaux on m'a prime
rénove il faut faire de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments ont je crois
que la plupart des dispositifs
aujourd'hui sont déjà conditionné si
vous voulez bénéficier de la prime à la
conversion automobile il faut acheter un
véhicule électrique ou un véhicule
critères 1
le seul point sur lequel je pense que
nous aurons un point de désaccord mais
je pense qu'il est bon aussi de ces sur
les impôts de production ses impôts de
production effectivement il y à une
baisse d'impôts de production moi
j'estime qu'on ne fait que se remettre à
peu près au niveau des autres pays
européens dont je ne vois pas pourquoi
on demanderait une conditionnalité là où
il s'agit simplement de fixer un cadre
global plus compétitif et plus attractif
pour les entreprises françaises
enfin mots de suez veolia j'entends ce
que vous dites sur la loi pacte et
j'écoute là encore toutes les remarques
moi je ne peux pas changer d'avis sur
cette affaire je suis en général c'est
constant la précipitation n'est jamais
bonne conseillère
donc on m'a expliqué il y a quelques
jours le 21 septembre tout à fait précis
que cette affaire devait être fait
toutes affaires cessantes et qu'on était
à 24 heures près moyennant quoi on s'est
précipité sans avoir les garanties
suffisantes ni sur l'emploi ni sur la
préservation de champion industriel est
là où je vous parle
l'affairé bloqués qu'est ce qui n'aurait
pas été plus sage de la part de
l'ensemble les industriels de prendre
encore plus le temps la discussion pour
trouver un accord amiable et éviter la
situation de blocage dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé aux trois
administrateurs représentant l'état au
conseil d'adminstration dungey de voter
contre cette opération pas sur le fond
de l'opération mais sur la manière dont
cette opération avait été conduite
je maintiens ma position l'état n'est
pas majoritaire dans le conseil il a été
battu mais je pense que c'était le rôle
de l'état de rappeler un certain nombre
de principes aux entreprises et de
manière beaucoup plus générale que cette
seule affaire veolia suez dans cette
place de crise économique chacun doit
s'interroger sur le rôle qu'il joue dans
l'économie les entreprises doivent
comprendre
que elles ont un rôle social à jouer
qu'elles ont une responsabilité sur
l'emploi qu'elles ont une responsabilité
sur l'environnement on n'arrivera pas à
construire un modèle économique plus
juste et plus efficace si chacun prend
pas ses responsabilités
donc je regrette la décision a été prise
par le conseil d'administration d' angie
je considère que nous aurions dû prendre
le temps d'un accord amiable et je
continue à considérer que la
préservation de l'emploi et la
préservation de la concurrence sur le
secteur
la gestion de l'eau la gestion des
déchets est importante pour notre pays
valérie létard sur action logement sujet
là aussi extrêmement important d'abord
vous me dire qu'un rapport de l'ige f et
qui n'a pas été transmis au parlement
je prends donc la décision de
transmettre ce rapport doligé f au
parlement je pense qu'il est bon que les
rapports de lits gf sur des sujets qui
intéressent l'ensemble des français puis
c'est être transmis au parlement
ça ne me pose pas de difficulté ensuite
des discussions sont en cours avec les
partenaires sociaux sont conduits par la
ministre du logement menée de wargon
j'aurais moi-même l'occasion de discuter
de ces sujets là avec les partenaires
sociaux chacun reconnaît il ya déjà un
diagnostic partagé que les dispositifs
existants ne sont pas satisfaisants
notamment pour la gouvernance que les
frais de fonctionnement sont trop élevés
et les partenaires sociaux je pense
partage ce diagnostic il faut donc que
nous parvenions à une réforme tout en
préservant le financement des politiques
publiques et en veillant aussi je le
rappelle a baissé l'apec qui est payée
par les entreprises et qui est un impôt
de production donc c'est dans ce cadre
là que doit s'inscrire
la réforme d'action logement pas
question de faire preuve de brutalité de
précipitations là encore nous négocions
les partenaires sociaux mais ils savent
que nous prendrons nos responsabilités
si jamais nous ne parvenons pas à un
accord sur ce sujet
joël labbé sur les questions
environnementales je veux juste rappeler
que plus d'un tiers du plan de relance
est consacré à ces questions là on nous
dit très souvent ça ne va pas
suffisamment vite il faut accélérer
là encore je pense que ce qui compte
c'est de ne rien renier de nos ambitions
mais d'avoir une visibilité sur le
calendrier sur le rythme auquel nous
faisons les choses il faut pas forcer la
réalité parce que sinon ça peut se payer
cher en terme d'emplois et donc aussi en
terme de crise sociale je pense que nous
avons été inscrits par ce qui s'est
passé sur la taxe carbone
moi je considère que c'est pas la taxe
carbone qui a provoqué le mouvement des
gilet jaune
c'est la conjugaison la taxe carbone et
de la convergence des tarifs du diesel
sur l'essence les deux à la fois c'était
sans doute très ambitieux sur le papier
est formidable mais c'était
insupportable pour des millions de nos
compatriotes
c'est la même chose enfin je tiens à
préciser et preuves à l'appui que bercy
en l'espèce avait alerté sur les risques
qu'il y avait à faire les deux à la fois
donc mais j'ai l'habitude de dire de
manière très transparente quelles sont
nos positions c'est la même chose qui
m'a amené sur la question du co2 et des
émissions de co2 a recommandé que on
fasse l'abaissement du seuil de
déclenchement du malus non pas en deux
ans mais en trois ans et si on veut
passer de 138 grammes de co2 par
kilomètre pour le seuil des cantons du
malus à 123 grammes ce qui était un saut
important notamment pour notre industrie
il est préférable de le faire en trois
ans de tenir cette ce calendrier est de
respecter des emplois industriels pour
qu'ils s'adaptent dans ces délais la
plutôt que de vouloir forcer la machine
haut risque au bout du compte deux cas
c'est beaucoup de choses
enfin daniel laurent un point pour finir
sur l'efficace viticole vous savez mon
attachement à cette filière et aux
produits de cette filière dont ils
auront toujours un peu mis l'économie et
des finances un grand défenseur des vins
et spiritueux français
simplement je ne pense pas que la bonne
politique avec l'administration
américaine est certainement pas celle de
monsieur trump
ce soit l'accommodement ou pour parler
de manière plus simple faire preuve de
faiblesse
nous avons été autorisés par
l'organisation mondiale du commerce a
imposé des sanctions sur les produits
américains à hauteur de 4 milliards
d'euros
nous avons le droit de le faire et bien
nous devons avoir aussi le courage de le
faire
monsieur trump mais les états unis de
manière générale ne respecteront que la
force si nous faisons preuve de
faiblesse alors même qu'ils ont déjà dit
que un accord à l'amiable était
impensable mais ont proposé d'accord à
l'amiable
nous avons négocié un accord qui aurait
été un accord entre alliés raisonnable
états unis et en europe les etats unis
n'en veulent pas le négociateur
américain n'en veut pas il faut être
capable de montrer que nous sommes
déterminés on ne gagne rien à faire
preuve de faiblesse et certainement pas
dans une négociation avec les états unis
nous sommes donc favorables à ce que
nous disions aux efforts que nous
utiliserons le droit de sanctionner des
produits américains qui nous a été
donnée par l'organisation mondiale du
commerce à hauteur de 4 milliard d'euros
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition de
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
était auditionné hier au sénat sur le
plan de relance et sur le projet de loi
de finances pour 2021 c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver toute l'actualité
parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une
excellente journée
[Musique]